Hallo
Pok oder nicht pok ist die frage chat
Ich tendiere aktuell noch zu nicht pok not pok
Hat jemand schon erfahrung mit einer zahn zusatzversicherung sammeln könnte
Wird immer noch am überlegen ob ich mich nicht komplett privat versichern lasse bis ich 40 bin
Der eigentlich das ist ja so dass magische alter bis wohin es noch irgendwie sinn macht
genug
kohle habe ich aber
ich muss mir dieses jahr irgendwie überlegen
sonst ist zu spät
Max ans trinken erinnern ja jetzt noch nicht jetzt noch nicht ging ja gerade erst los
Manchmal dass das habe ich jetzt die letzten jahre über vor schon öfters
festgestellt weil weil boomer hirn und so
ich rede mittlerweile
öfters schneller als ich denke
Das war was das habe ich früher besser hinbekommen
Da habe ich quasi genauso schnell gedacht wie geredet aber heute
Das ist halt das heißt wenn ich manchmal sätze mache wo das letzte wort nicht passt
Dann liegt es daran dass ich das letzte wort schon aussprechen bevor mein brain das letzte wort prozess hat
zoomstick vermute ich nee nee
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher was das für leads biegt ist
looms dick dank für den sub
Oder lehm leum stick
leum stick
aber dankeschön für den prime sub extrem
extremly ex
Glasfaser wer legt sich schon kupfer ins hirn was wird heute gemacht
high iq leute produziert
Ist er hat schon geholfen ist schon wieder iq plus plus
naja
so ein bisschen schon ich merke das manchmal
dass wenn ich
Was sage und dann mit also gerade beim stream ist das ist das doppelt kompliziert so
Ich sag was denkt darüber nach was ich jetzt quasi gleich sage und dann gucke ich so mit einem auge auf den chat
Und stell fest ich kann nicht chat lesen und verstehen und dabei sinnvolles zeug erzählen und noch irgendwas hier am rechner machen
Da fährt man einmal bahnanschluss verpasst ja so ist das
Ich kann dir aber auch aber auch sagen wenn du öfters bahn fährst dann ist es auch so
Es liegt nicht nur an dem einmal bahn fahren der anteil von sachen die nicht pünktlich sind ist da
Allgemein sehr hoch deswegen hast du gute chancen dass wenn du öfters bahn fährst du auch relativ oft verspätung hast
Muss man kurz betriebssystem update machen
Let's check box abschrift schön 33 monate am start alter ihr seid schon welche
Ja guck mal hier und wie lang ist der
loom stick am start vier monate
Du hast fast den goldenen keks schon
Machen wir die ganzen krempel wieder zu muss ich muss mal kurz schauen
Wie viele pull request wie viele issues habe ich offen auf 16 ok ich musste echt mal ran ich habe mir schon gedanken zugemacht
Den fiat champ zu updaten aber ich habe so aktuell kaum motivation und zeit und bock
Es wäre echt mal wieder
Zeit weil ich glaube wenn ich mein home assistant update dann habe ich auch probleme dass er nicht mehr richtig funktioniert
Oder scam train ist ab das ging aber jetzt ist der ist heute instant am start der scam train
Erstmal erst mal die vm rebooten das hat priorität
Hype lull kann man gewinnen hype lull hype hype cool also hype lull ist eigentlich ganz nice
Aber der rest ist so na ja
Aber hype lull ist tatsächlich ganz neises emote
Aber das scam train das ist wichtig leute ihr müsst ihr müsst ihr müsst euch die beiden lassen
Der muss demnächst mal wieder ins weltall fliegen glaube ich
Die playlist ist unterschiedlich laut das sagt
Gute frage ich guck mal was meine stocks machen
Max hast du eigentlich die firma der ssd geupdatet ja habe ich hat ohne probleme funktioniert
ohne probleme funktioniert
Lass mich mal kurz gucken was meine stocks machen
Meine stocks können nicht richtig geladen werden gerade weil scalable probleme hat wie es aussieht was ist da los sorry for the inconvenience
Jetzt geht's jetzt geht's okay
Also meine stocks na ja na ja
na ja
Also
Letzte woche 294 euro
Das ist jetzt ja nicht die welt
Keine giga stocks
Es gibt übrigens neue white people happy ist wirklich echt wo was wie
zeigt zeigen zeigen also auf github noch nicht
Im discord oder wo gibt es die oder hast du mir geschickt
E-mails ok moment leute neue white people happy
Jetzt wird sich bei mir sicher ob ich in der e mail eingeloggt bin die müssen wir jetzt checken
wichtigste news des tages
Ich manche messages auf youtube sind schon sehr wert irgendwie
Zeig mal ja noch
Neue white people happy ist also
Oh der ist gut der ist gut okay ich zeige ich zeige euch das ganze mal
Geil
Nudeln mit lachse
Ok leute neue neue white people happy backgrounds
ich
präsentiere euch
der
der iron champ 3000
pump pump champ
Und jetzt und jetzt kommt das und jetzt kommt das beste
nudeln mit lachs
Das ist echt geil
nudeln mit lachs champ
ok runterladen download
download
Hahaha
doch
nudeln mit lachs sind halt pock ja
So repos ich bin mir gar nicht sicher wo habe ich das ganze liegen hier white people happy desktop background mal pullen falls ich nicht hier das aktuelle hab
doch habe ich cp downloads
Quatsch hier downloads
Wie fängt das an mit xpp
Ach so jetzt haben wir mehrere
Wir sind alle day oder
Wow
warte
Das ist es nicht energy ist es auch nicht
energy ist es nicht
iron ist es
noodles ist es
Das ist es auch nicht sport ist es
eine
Ich muss das jetzt muss ich das ganze noch verschieben
nach images
images
sind status da könnt ihr euch gleich das ganze pullen falls irgendjemand bock hat
und jetzt müssen wir glaube ich die reed die noch anpassen wenn ich das richtig sehe
hier day
day
guck mal da kann das hier damit noch
noodles
dann haben wir noch
iron oder ein
sagen ja da die engländer zu sprechen dass er ja nicht und sport aber hier preview da ist es
geht status jetzt jetzt jetzt kommit jetzt push origin um weil wir jetzt auf github gucken
dann sollte es da schon eingetroffen sei ja nudel mit lachs beste okay der ist auch nice
ich weiß nicht
ob der ob der so wirklich in die normalen desktop hintergründe passt das habe ich da
jetzt angeklickt bin ich jetzt rausgekommen desktop notifications okay los los um all
verdanken für den zapf der ist nicht schlecht das ist das ist richtig kona style hell hell
ja weißt du weißt du was doch übelst lustig wäre falls das falls das gescheit falls das
gescheit aussieht wenn hier oben
unten rechts das kona emot daneben sitzen würde und die flagge halten ja das ist ja auch die logik
die da viele verfolgen so nach dem motto was machst du denn wenn du nachts von einem einbrecher in
deinem haus überrascht wirst und er hat eine pistole dann brauchst du was besseres als der
hat es ist kona logik russische variante probieren probier mal ob du das noch hinkriegst dass der
dass der kona die flagge hält dann push ich dann push ich rein
konnte letzten stream nur kurz reinschauen haben die steckdosen was getaugt also die
steckdosen die haben sich flashen lassen wenn auch nur sehr widerwillig aber ob die was taugen bin ich
unschlüssig die sind sehr rudimentär also die haben also von den features her die kannst du
remote ein und ausschalten der usb anschluss ist immer an und irgendwie leistung der angeschlossenen
geht damit auch nicht also die sind feature technisch schon an der untersten stelle der
anderen seite habe ich die bekommen 9 euro 4 oder 10 euro für vier stück was natürlich unschlagbar
günstig ist aber die waren beim flashen etwas etwas widerspenstig da musste ich kabel anlöten
und das war extrem klein ich musste sogar zum ersten mal eine dünne löt spitze auf meinen
lötkolben machen ich hätte einfach gedacht machte sie mode daneben und gut ist hast du
dich eigentlich auf deinen neuen jobkurs vorbereitet habe heute meinen vertrag
unterschrieben am ersten zehnten geht's los eigentlich nicht wirklich großartig weil meine
bewerbung und die skills haben halt super zum neuen job gepasst ja doch ich habe mir und das
habt ihr auch im stream gesehen wir haben uns noch mal ein bisschen vertieft wieder kubernetes
angeschaut
auch ein paar sachen die im vorfeld noch nicht gemacht habe weil ich wusste ja nicht genau was
da auf mich zukommt aber das was wir hier im stream gemacht haben ist viel advanced als das
was wir mit kombiniert ist auf der arbeit machen insofern nicht weiter wild neuer scams schon wieder
was ist denn hier los der besos muss ins weltall ich sehe schon anki dankeschön für den sub du hast
nicht zufällig pass of exile guides geschrieben oder ach nee der hat der typ von pass of exile
hieß enki jetzt habe ich durchgebracht weil den ersten charakter den ich in pass of exile
erstellt habe war nach einem guide von enki kann mich noch daran erinnern aber ich dachte ich dachte
anki enki heißt ja da hast du danke für den sub subscription hier richtig auf dem weg wieder ich
sehe ich schon ich spürs schon chat ist heute einfach komplett überlegen der schlauste chat
auf twitch aber achtung achtung das verfällt mit der zeit das geht wieder runter also es ist
nicht so, dass man einmal subscribt und dann immer
High IQ. Das wäre auch zu einfach.
Eine Milliarde, dankeschön,
Pog-Subscriptions, äh, Bits.
Ähm.
Was würdest du empfehlen,
wenn ich Bock auf,
guck mal, jetzt hier, heute ist der Scam-Train mal richtig
am Pog-Champen.
Was würdest du mir empfehlen, wenn ich Bock auf
Linux-Server-Admin
habe,
aber mein Ausbildungsbetrieb
eigentlich nur Windows-Umgebung verwendet?
Bald sollen wir Linux
Admins kriegen und ich könnte das passend mit der
Ausbildung schaffen für die Stelle. Ja, dann sag denen
doch, Leute. Ja, Moment mal.
Die wollen Linux
Admins kaufen, obwohl die noch gar
kein Linux haben? Ich meine, ich will mich da
nicht beschweren. Das ist ja eigentlich
streng genommen keine schlechte Idee,
dass wenn man damit anfängt, dass man schon Experten
dafür da hat, aber trotzdem, meistens
ist das ja so ein etwas fließender Prozess.
Also ich würde, ich würde ganz
klar sagen, dass das was ist in die
Richtung, du dich weiterentwickeln willst, wie man
das so schön immer nennt. Und
normalerweise ist es ja auch so, dass
neue Stellen erstmal intern
geöffnet werden
und da kannst du gleich sagen, ich bewerbe mich da.
Naja, auf
ja, spricht nichts dagegen.
Ich finde das gut, ganz ehrlich.
Ich persönlich hätte überhaupt
keinen Bock auf Windows-Admin-Geschiss,
aber jeder soll das machen, was er will.
Darf ich dich mal fragen,
das interessiert mich wirklich jetzt, und Chat, falls jemand
von euch in der ähnlichen Situation ist,
interessiert mich das von euch auch.
Was ist der Grund, warum man
als, sagen wir mal, Windows-Admin
doch lieber
in die Linux-Richtung möchte?
Weil, umgedreht,
Linux-Admins, die in die Windows-Richtung gehen,
kenne ich nicht einen.
Deswegen interessiert mich mal, was
der ausschlaggebende Grund ist.
Kann ja alles sein, du musst mir jetzt gar nicht sagen,
weil ich Linux so viel geiler finde, man, vielleicht
ist es ja auch, weil du denkst, es hat bessere Zukunft
im Jobmarkt
oder, keine Ahnung.
Würde mich aber einfach mal interessieren, warum?
Darkblue, danke schön für den
Sub.
Holzklasse, ein Monat, POG-Subscription, ja.
Es ist extrem.
Nord meinem
Chef, dass Linux die Zukunft ist und die
Kosten für Windows-Maschinen...
Ey, da muss ich sagen,
das ist ein guter Chef, der weiß...
Ich weiß nicht, ob er weiß, wo... Ich wollte gerade sagen,
der weiß, wovon er redet, das weiß man natürlich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, ob der weiß, wovon er redet,
aber zumindest, wenn
er wüsste, wovon er redet,
dann würde ich ihm zustimmen.
Ja, gerade auf Servern, gell?
Ja, stehen, danke.
Danke schön für den Sub. Sag mal, haben wir Dark
zusammengespielt?
Vom Namen her kommt mir das bekannt vor.
Hatten wir mal ein paar ein bisschen gelevelt?
Ah ja, dann warst du das. Nice, nice.
Hast du gesehen? Hast du gesehen? Es gibt
im Ende des Jahres
und gerade dabei sind...
Ey, nicht Phoenix, Schwachsinn.
Es gibt eine zweite Season
auf Eden. Sind die bescheuert?
Die haben noch gar nichts dazu geschrieben.
Kacknoobs, Alter.
Sowas muss man auch schreiben.
Nicht so bei denen im Discord.
Es gibt im Herbst
eine neue Season auf Eden.
Also, wenn du Bock hast, wir sind wieder am Start.
Du willst ja wieder nur zergen.
Ey, ja.
Ich kann kein krasses
Eggman-Zeug mehr machen ohne die festen Leute.
Ich würde durchaus ganz gerne
mal wieder die ein oder anderen
8 vs. 8 Sachen spielen,
aber da haben wir einfach nicht die Leute für.
Da auch keine Achtergruppen.
Und das Dumme ist,
ganz ehrlich, es gibt ja doch ein paar,
die gerne 8 vs. 8 spielen.
Das Problem ist nur,
dass das meiste
irgendwelche alten,
sich selbst viel zu wichtig
nehmenden, elitären Spacken sind.
So wie ich früher auch hinterher auch gewesen bin.
Aber die sind anscheinend die letzten
20 Jahre komplett hängen geblieben im Kopf.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit den Spielern los ist.
Aber Herbst geht's wieder los.
Also, wenn du Bock hast, sag im Discord Bescheid.
Ich glaub, du hast mich ja noch
in der Liste. Sag Bescheid oder
schreib auf Twitter oder wo auch immer und dann...
Kannst du gleich mitleveln von Anfang an, wenn du willst.
Wir fangen ja dann wieder mit so
5, 6 Leuten an.
EDV-Forensik.
Moin. Das ist so ein richtig
krasser Oldschool-Name, muss ich mal
sagen. EDV-Forensik.
Das klingt so ein bisschen wie
zu Zeiten, als man noch
Telefongespräche
in der Vermittlungsstelle gepatcht
hat und sowas.
Das ist richtig schön
Oldschool.
Die, die Holz. Danke schon für den Sub.
Leute, ich muss... Ich hab's gemerkt.
Ich muss öfter solche Streamtitel machen.
Heute in den ersten 5 Minuten
direkt irgendwie 10 Subs oder so.
Übrigens, Chat.
Soll ich euch mal was Erfreuliches sagen?
Wollt ihr es hören, Chat?
Erfreuliche News?
Force Champ?
Und zwar... Naja, wirklich für euch
weiß ich nicht, wie erfreulich das ist.
Ich bin schwanger.
Ja, nicht alles verraten.
Jetzt.
Nein. Regelmäßig
streamen lohnt sich. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Was natürlich auch Motivation
ist, weiter regelmäßig zu streamen.
Ich hab jetzt diesen Monat
tatsächlich fast
ohne Ausnahmen
jeden Tag, jeden zweiten Tag gestreamt
und ich hab so viele Subs
wie noch nie vorher. Also es lohnt
sich anscheinend.
Dann kann ich die Mods bezahlen. Ich bezahl meine
Mods doch schon in Exposure.
Ja.
Hat sie so ein grünes Ding neben dem Namen.
Das reicht es, reicht es etwa nicht?
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, äh,
Mods nicht bezahlen und Leute nicht bezahlen.
Ich hab heute mit, ich hab mich doch letztens
bei euch im Chat mal ein bisschen drüber
ausgekotzt, was da eSport technisch
im Hintergrund für, für shady Sachen
laufen. Gerade so auf
deutscher und europäischer, äh,
Tier, Tier eins und zwei Ebene.
Ich hab heute ein Video aufgenommen
mit einem
Bekannten, der
bis vor ein paar Wochen
für eine europäische
E-Sport-Organisation oder
die letzte, für drei europäische
E-Sport-Organisationen gearbeitet hat in den letzten paar
Jahren. Und da haben wir eine Stunde
geschwätzt. Das müssen wir noch ein bisschen schneiden.
Aber da sind echt haarsträubende Dinger
dabei. Von
Verträgen, an die sich nicht
gehalten wird, zu
Überweisungen in Kryptowährungen, die nie ankommen
und so. Das ist super shady Business.
Woher weißt du das?
Hehe.
Ja gut, wer sonst?
Ja.
Aber Vetrins ist nicht, also der Moritz ist nicht
der einzige, von dem ich so Sachen
gehört habe. Ich mach, ich mach
das jetzt seit 13 Jahren auf YouTube
und ich hab das schon zu Call of Duty-Zeiten immer wieder
gehört. Von Preisgeldern, die nicht ausbezahlt
wurden, von Spielergehältern, die nicht,
die nicht bezahlt wurden, von Sponsoring-Sachen, die nicht
eingehalten wurden. Nee, nicht
Gambling. Nicht Gambling.
Also wirklich, also nicht
E-Sport-Rahmen, sondern
wirklich Spielerverträge, die nicht eingehalten wurden.
Leute, die Gehälter beinhalten,
die nie ausbezahlt wurden und so was.
Leute, die auf
Training-Camps in andere Länder
geschickt wurden und dort nichts zu
Essen bekommen haben und so was.
Das ist ganz, ganz furchtbar abenteuerlich,
was da im Hintergrund läuft.
Natürlich reden wir hier nicht
von Weltklasse
CSGO-Teams,
die Millionen verdienen,
natürlich nicht. Wir reden hier
ein bisschen von ein bisschen kleineren Brötchen auf
deutscher und europäischer Ebene.
E-Sport-technisch. Aber nicht desto
trotz, da läuft dann auch viel Shit im Hintergrund.
Soll früher schlimmer gewesen sein?
Ja, höchstwahrscheinlich schon.
Aber jetzt ist es mit Systemen
schlimm.
Gerade, weil die das extrem ausnutzen, wenn
die Spieler aus osteuropäischen Ländern haben,
die dann von daheim wegziehen und
die man halt
easy in der Hand hat.
Vielleicht ist euch auch schon mal aufgefallen,
dass im E-Sport das öfters vorkommt,
als man denkt, weil manchmal,
wenn der Frust so groß ist, schreiben ja manche
Spieler auf Twitter.
Und dann wird das Ganze immer furchtbar schnell geregelt.
So nach dem Motto, oh, da wussten wir ja gar nichts
vor und nach. Ja, jetzt ist alles wieder gut.
Obwohl die Spieler schon irgendwie
drei Jahre auf ihr Geld warten, teilweise.
Naja. Müssen wir gucken, das müssen wir
schneiden, das Video. Und dann gibt's demnächst
mal ein, wir reden uns ein bisschen
über E-Sport-Bedingungen auf Video. Ich weiß,
dass das nicht mehr so richtig
in mein aktuelles
Channel, ich will, ich wage
es nicht mal Konzept zu nennen,
weil ich relativ wenig
Gaming- und E-Sport-Content in letzter Zeit
mache, aber da muss man einfach was zu sagen.
Scheiß drauf, ob der Algorithmus das mag
oder nicht.
Also, wir haben über eine Stunde aufgenommen,
gecuttet ist das Video wahrscheinlich.
Wow, Alter, ist ja gut.
Jetzt übertreibt man nicht.
Da ist,
da ist einer befördert worden.
Kann das sein, Sergeant Silver?
Oder gab's Gehaltserhöhung oder sowas?
Ähm, ja, danke.
25 Subscriber.
Krasser Scheiß hier.
Jetzt bin ich Millionär.
Wer hat denn was gekriegt hier?
Was soll's sein? Der Red Doctor,
Spelunke, SoNice,
Imperial, GTK,
ja, alter Battlefield-Veteran
hier am Start.
Believe Lucas, Worti auch wieder am Start.
DotProject, Max2Tan,
der ist auch schon lange am Start.
Winnie hab' ich auch schon hier öfters gesehen.
Päh, der Captain Porgas hat einen Sub gewonnen.
Ja, der hat's als Modgehen natürlich verdient.
Anki,
wie kannst du Anki
einen Sub giften? Der hat doch eben,
Moment, eben war es Anki,
der einen Sub
reingehauen hat. Jetzt ist es Anki,
der einen Sub gewonnen hat.
Mein Gott, Leute, ihr überfordert mich mit den Namen.
Der Eichler, auch am Start.
Xenoblade, Stufmann,
Xaiti,
Rizzino, Superbasti,
Foidei,
auch wieder am Start. Der ist ja der Subbox-Camper.
Deluxe hier, Splixxer
und DanielDigital88
Pock hier. Dankeschön, Leute.
Äh, oder was heißt, also, nicht Leute, äh,
Sarge & Silver.
Die haben mich nicht alle gesubscribed, sondern nur einer hat
gegiftet. Und wer hat gedodged?
Wer hat gedodged? Jawoll.
Ja. Kann ich nicht aussprechen.
Hat gedodged.
Blackripper hat gedodged. Mindscore hat gedodged.
Killrog, alle gedodged.
EasyDodged, FreshFrog, EasyDodged.
Ja. Pock.
Nice.
Jetzt habe ich ein bisschen
den Faden verloren, aber nee, ich glaube, mit dieser
eSports-Geschichte war ich jetzt ja durch.
Du, du,
du, du, du.
Ah, stimmt, ich wollte mir noch ein Video angucken. Vielleicht können wir uns
das zusammen angucken.
Ich habe nämlich gesehen, es gab halt ein neues
Video. Das ist neu
in, ja, das ist übrigens JavaScript,
wer das nicht kennt.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
heißt JavaScript ja nicht JavaScript.
Also, der JavaScript-Standard
heißt ja nicht JavaScript, sondern
ECMAScript. Hat eigentlich irgendjemand eine Ahnung,
warum das nicht einfach
JavaScript heißt, sondern ECMAScript?
Das ist JavaScript.
Aber...
Ach, Moment. Ist das Standard für
Scripting-Languages including
JavaScript, JScript,
ActionScript.
It is also best known
as JavaScript-Standard. Ja, genau.
Ich meine, der Einfachheit
halber, warum nennt man das denn nicht einfach
JavaScript-Standard?
Schon gesehen, Golo, bester Mann.
Ja, bei...
Ich gucke ja die Videos echt gerne von ihm,
gerade weil die immer sehr on point
sind und man weiß, wovon er spricht.
Bei Golo denke ich ja manchmal, er ist
ein Echsenmensch. Wisst ihr warum?
Vielleicht sieht man das gleich in dem Video.
Verschwörungstheorie.
Weil, ich glaube, der hat einen Teleprompter,
Teleprompter nennt man ja nicht, so ein
Monitor rechts neben sich stehen
und der guckt manchmal
so rechts auf den Monitor und macht
ihm dann die Augen zu. Und dann denke ich
immer, alter,
kek Alu,
Echsenmensch enttarnt.
Das hört gar nicht mehr auf
zu bimmeln wegen den Subs, oder?
Das kommt nicht mehr hinterher.
Das hört überhaupt nicht mehr auf.
Guck mal hier, was du angerichtet hast.
Ach, schon selber.
Jetzt hast du die Queue
vollgemacht bei
Steamlabs oder was auch immer ich für die Subs verwende.
Ich weiß gar nicht genau.
Jetzt hast du die AWS-Rechnung oder
Firebase-Rechnung von denen
in die Höhe getrieben.
Weil ich hab natürlich kein kostenpflichtiges Abo
bei Steamlabs.
Was ist deine Meinung zu BattleBit Remastered?
Hast du das Video
schon geguckt?
Oder warst du auch einer der,
die mich im Stream fragen,
was ist, weil es nicht in der Abo-Box
beziehungsweise im Feed gewesen ist?
Ich hab von vielen Leuten gehört,
explizit bei diesem Video,
dass es nicht im Feed drin war.
Anscheinend der Meinung
juckt nicht.
War das bei dir auch nicht im Feed drin?
Oh, die Leute sind übelst böse,
weil ich gesagt habe, ich mag die Pixel.
Die Pixel-Grafik sieht mir teilweise zu platt aus.
Guck mal hier, die letzten paar Tagen
sind sie richtig, richtig hier...
Guck mal hier.
Dein Video ist einfach Müll.
Und man...
Jetzt geht's los, passt auf.
Dein Video ist einfach Müll.
Und man merkt, dass du nicht 1984 geboren bist.
Exposed.
Sondern 1999 oder so.
Auf gar keinen Fall 1984.
Das hört man ja schon an der Stimme.
Und deine Gründe sind auch so sinnlos,
wie ein Haus im Meer zu bauen.
Tja...
Exposed würde ich sagen.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
ich hätte keine Probleme,
1999 geboren zu sein.
1999 wäre extremely pog,
dann wäre ich jetzt 24.
Das ist ungefähr das, glaube ich,
so in dem Dreh, wie ich mit YouTube angefangen habe,
seit zehn Jahren ungefähr.
Ah, nicht ganz. Fast.
Wäre ich dabei.
1999, easy.
Hauptsache vor 2000.
Weil alle
nach 2000 sind
dumm.
Aber unter 2000
beste.
True.
Und natürlich, wie das ist,
es gibt selbstverständlich keine Ausnahmen.
Es ist ultimativ so, wenn ich das sage.
Ja, okay.
Und dann hat er noch ein bisschen weiter geflamed.
Oh, guck mal hier.
Der G-Bait-Punkt ist am Part.
Das ist verdammt noch mal
keine Pixel-Grafik, sondern Low-Poly-Grafik.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich das in dem Video
oder in meinem letzten Battle-Bit-Video
exakt so genannt habe.
Ich glaube, im letzten Battle-Bit-Video
habe ich es Low-Polygon-Look genannt.
Und jetzt habe ich es, glaube ich,
Pixel-Look genannt.
Zumindest zu dem anderen
klar, seid ihr alle kritikfreudig.
Ihr kommt auch aus einer Ecke,
die einfach alles nur scheiße findet,
sobald es keinen Battlefield-Grafik hat.
Oder es sich wie Battlefield anhört
und ihr habt einfach keine Ahnung,
was ein gutes Spiel ausmacht.
Ich möchte noch mal festhalten,
dass ich wirklich bedingungsloser
Battlefield-Fan bin,
wie man auch ganz klar
erkennen kann,
wie man eindeutig
an diesem Video auch
sofort merkt.
Der Absturz von Battlefield.
Ich bin einfach
bedingungskompletter Fanboy.
Leute, ich glaube, man sieht schon,
dass ich ab hier
jemanden gefunden habe,
der
Thumbnails für mich erstellt, oder?
Ab hier so.
Wobei ich sagen muss,
so mies waren
die alten Thumbnails doch auch nicht
für selbst gemacht, oder?
Die gingen doch eigentlich schon ganz gut klar.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen
advanceres WordArt.
Du findest Thumbnails overrated?
Das sieht YouTube anders.
Ich habe einen Sub bekommen?
Echt, wo? Ja, habe ich doch alle schon.
Ja, keine Ahnung, was mit dem abgeht.
AI-Thumbnails.
Ja, ich finde, man erkennt das meistens,
wenn es AI-Thumbnails sind.
So, was wollte ich denn jetzt eigentlich ursprünglich?
Ich bin jetzt erst mal 30 Minuten
Sidetracked gewesen. Ich wollte euch da noch
irgendwas erzählen ursprünglich.
Wo habe ich denn angefangen?
Ich habe schon wieder alles vergessen.
Thumbnails siehst du eh nicht, du hast Clickbait-Remover.
Ja, aber was steht denn in den Videotiteln
dann? Die Videotitel sind ja genauso Clickbait
wie Thumbnails.
ECMAScript. Stimmt, ja.
Da habe ich mich gerade drüber ausgelassen.
Ja, wie gesagt, warum?
Warum heißt dieser Camp...
Warum heißt dieser Camp
nicht einfach JavaScript-Standard,
sondern ECMAScript?
Okay, das gibt es ja, glaube ich, auch erst seit 2013.
Okay, nein.
Aber die regelmäßigen
Sachen gibt es, glaube ich, erst seit
2003.
ES5, genau.
ES5 war 2013?
Oder?
Wann kam ES5 raus?
2009!
Ne, dann meine ich
was anderes. 2009
ist ja schon hyper
hyper aktuell.
Ja, aber
ich finde halt, bei sowas könnte man es einfach
JavaScript nennen, weil die meisten Leute damit was anfangen.
Immerhin,
eins muss man sagen,
JavaScript ist durch die gute Arbeit
dieses JavaScript-Gremiums
oder Workgroup...
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die genau machen,
ehrlich gesagt. Im Prinzip sind es wahrscheinlich
die großen Browser-Hersteller,
die da den Ton angeben,
aber man sieht
an den JavaScript-Standards,
dass man eine Sprache
innerhalb von
sagen wir mal,
fünf bis zehn Jahren
von echt abartig
zu
ist nett zu benutzen
umformen kann.
Beim C++-Standard sieht man,
wie man eine Sprache, die ursprünglich schon
abartig war, noch immer weiter abartiger
macht. Doch
JavaScript ist mittlerweile wirklich gut
zu benutzen.
JavaScript hat ein paar historische Sachen, die sind
fail, ja. Zum Beispiel gleich gleich gleich
oder
oder true gleich gleich
und solche Dinger. Ja, es gibt schon Sachen,
die sind sehr merkwürdig, aber
insgesamt
ist JavaScript echt eine Sprache,
die kann man gut benutzen mittlerweile.
Also meiner Meinung nach
ich glaube,
die müssten das normale gleich gleich
obsolet machen, weil das die
unbekannte ist.
Also die undefinierte.
Also ich meine, gut, die könnten das alte
rausschmeißen und das gleich gleich gleich
zu gleich gleich machen und sowas.
Ich bäsche nicht C.
Ich bäsche C++.
Gegen C sag ich nix, aber C++ ist von
der ekligen Sprache zu der noch ekligeren Sprache
geworden mit den
neueren Standards. Mit vereinzelt
guten Sachen drinne.
Ja.
Ach, da fällt mir ein, ich wollte mit euch ja noch
ein anderes Video gucken. Habe ich
nämlich letztens angefangen zu schauen,
war ein Konferenztalk.
Den fand ich,
zumindest den Anfang fand ich nicht schlecht,
das hier. Aber das kommen wir jetzt
nicht, das ist zu lang.
Fünf, fünf Minuten hier.
Programming's
greatest Mistakes. Da geht es
zum Beispiel um
Sicherheitslücken,
CPU-Bugs,
Stonks,
Aktienfonds, die pleite gegangen sind,
weil sie sinnlose Sachen gekauft
haben, also AI
basiert sinnlose Sachen gekauft haben.
Und es geht
um den Madfile-Unfucker.
Bester Name überhaupt.
Wir gucken uns, wir gucken
uns jetzt an, was
die, was der neue JavaScript-Standard
so hergibt.
Geöffnete Tab-Anzahl beim Troubleshooting.
Ich habe die Tab-Anzahl auch ohne
Troubleshooting geöffnet, weil
ich mir immer denke,
freier Rahmen ist verschenkter Rahmen. Ah!
Da geht noch was, da geht noch was.
Ich sollte, ich sollte noch ein paar Sachen starten
hier, noch ein paar VMs. Was ist mit
der hier? Das ist was für ein
Aufwachstream, das dauert 50 Minuten, dauert dann
drei Stunden, ja. Ja, das ist halt das
Ding, wenn ich das jetzt gucke,
wenn wir das jetzt gucken.
Wir gucken uns jetzt erstmal an, was
der neueste JavaScript-Standard so
hergibt.
Hattest du das auch mit der Steckdose
hinbekommen? Habe deine Antwort vorher nicht mitbekommen.
Ja,
habe ich. Aber ich würde die Steckdosen
trotzdem nicht empfehlen.
Habe ich hinbekommen. Hat funktioniert.
Wenn auch echt
eklig, weil man sehr kleine
Teile zusammenlöten musste, aber es hat
funktioniert. Also könnte man schon
sagen, ganz schön pog.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, leider.
Leider. Ich weiß gar nicht, Leute,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich meinen RAM vollbekommen soll.
Habt ihr Vorschläge? Wie kriege ich meinen RAM voll?
Okay, wir machen jetzt einen Plan. Max, Max sein RAM
muss ausgelastet werden. Was soll er
machen? Was, was ist die beste
Variante, um RAM zu verbraten?
Loopen. Loopen
brauche ich zwangsläufig. RAM Benchmark.
Ah. Die brauchen meistens
nicht so viel auf einmal.
Forkbomb.
Geht das unter Windows überhaupt gescheit?
Wahrscheinlich muss ich einfach
auf 5 VMs starten oder so.
Echt, das ist eine Windows Forkbomb? Wirklich?
Also die Bash Forkbomb
verstehe ich ja, wie sie funktioniert. Die
Windows Forkbomb checke ich nicht.
Microsoft Teams starten, das stimmt.
Sind erstmal 5 GB weg.
Egal, lasst uns jetzt mal angucken, was es
Neues gibt. Blender
und Unity starten.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, das ist auch so ein Ding, was ich
nicht verstehe im Startmenü.
Ernsthaft, dieser kleine Button
hier oben, ne, ist
eigentlich mit der
wichtigste Button im ganzen Startmenü.
Aber der ist einfach so klein
und
vor allem, warum ist das so wenig ben-
Ach, egal. Ich darf mich nicht über Windows aufregen.
Wenn ich damit anfange,
dann
dann höre ich nicht auf. Das ist wie wenn
ich mich über C++ aufrege.
Es gibt so zwei Sachen,
wenn ich damit anfange, dann hört es nicht mehr auf.
Okay, also, let's go.
Was ist neu in JavaScript
2000...
JavaScript 2023.
10 Minuten Video, oder?
Da wird es nicht allzu viel Neues geben.
Also, eine Sache habe ich im Hinterkopf, die ist
neu. Und zwar...
Es gibt jetzt...
Oder war das schon im letzten
Standard?
Die neuen Date-Time-Funktionen?
Waren die schon...
Waren die schon im letzten Standard?
Erst 2022, oder?
Ja.
Ich glaube, das ist das, was ich meine.
Oder...
Ist das...
Oder gibt es das noch gar nicht?
Übrigens, das ist eine sehr gute Webseite.
Oh, das gibt es noch nirgendswo.
Aber JavaScript hat doch
neue Sachen für Date-Time bekommen
mittlerweile.
Oder bringe ich das durcheinander und das gab es noch gar nicht?
Naja, anscheinend
gab es das noch nicht.
Weil...
Was nimmt man denn in
JavaScript für ordentliche Date-Time?
Ich kenne das hier.
Das ist ganz okay. Das habe ich jetzt schon öfters mal benutzt.
Da kann man ganz gutes
Date-Time-Handling damit machen.
Moment.js gab es früher noch.
Das soll man ja aber irgendwie nicht mehr verwenden.
Wie macht ihr
Date-Time-Geschichten in JavaScript?
So, dass es nicht kompletter
Clusterfuck und Painschamp ist.
Also, mir
fällt spontan nur das da ein.
Skillkiller,
danke schön für den Sub.
18 Monate Hyper-Subscription.
Wie weit kommen wir
in dem Video ohne abzuschweifen?
Oh, das JavaScript-Ding.
Das hat ja noch nicht mal angefangen und ich bin schon abgeschwiffen.
Also, insofern
schauen wir mal.
Spannend.
Okay, Leute.
Jetzt aber. Jetzt gucken wir das Video.
Also, was ist neu in
JavaScript 2023?
Erzählt uns
Golo von The Native Web.
Vor knapp drei Wochen, nämlich am Dienstag,
dem 27. Juni,
wurde die neue Version des Sprachstandards
von Java...
... nämlich ECMAScript 2023
oder einfach kurz
ES 2023 veröffentlicht.
Das Ganze ist zumindest meiner
persönlichen Meinung nach dieses Jahr ein bisschen
untergegangen. Zumindest habe ich keine
großen Schlagzeilen dazu mitbekommen.
Und das liegt sicherlich auch daran, dass
ES 2023 keine
speziellen Features enthält, auf die alle
Entwicklerinnen und Entwickler händeringend
gewartet hätten.
Ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht, was da wirklich dabei ist.
Wie gesagt, ich dachte DateTime ist dabei,
aber DateTime ist anscheinend
gar nicht dabei.
Also, insofern kein Plan, was da eigentlich dabei ist.
Ganz spannende Version,
denn es werden ein paar erste Schritte...
Du musst auch bald auf Windows 11 wechseln, MonkaS.
... eine interessante Richtung unternommen.
Und welche das sind und was es in dieser Version
überhaupt alles Neues gibt,
das erfährst du in diesem Video.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen
zu unserem neuen Developers Dictionary.
Auf geht's.
Das wusste ich gar nicht, dass das jedes Jahr kommt.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich habe das nie so genau verfolgt.
Aber es gibt viele andere Features.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
Echsenmensch.
Ich habe es genau gesehen.
Guckt mal her.
Revealed.
Keck Alu.
... von ECMAScript 2016
bis einschließlich 2021.
Und dieses Video,
das findest du hier oben in der Infocard.
Ja, und das andere Video,
das war dann vor einem Jahr,
war das Video zu ECMAScript 2022,
wo es dann quasi nur noch um die Neuerungen
dieser einen Version ging.
Das heißt, wenn du dir überhaupt erstmal
einen generellen Überblick verschaffen möchtest,
dann fang mit dem gerade eben verlinkten Video an.
Und wenn du im Vorfeld aber einfach nochmal
die Features vom vergangenen Jahr auffrischen möchtest...
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was wie wann in JavaScript dazu gekommen ist.
Aber trotzdem, ich kann es nochmal betonen,
nach C-Sharp,
das würde er hier wahrscheinlich übrigens
komplett anders sehen mittlerweile,
aber nach C-Sharp ist JavaScript tatsächlich
die zweitbeliebteste Sprache.
Normalerweise würde ich sagen Ruby,
aber Ruby ist halt leider
komplett bedeutungslos geworden
die letzten Jahre über.
Die Sprache Ruby,
also die Programmiersprache,
mag ich wirklich.
Und ich würde auch gerne mehr in Ruby machen,
aber Rails ist halt komplett durch.
Niemand macht mehr was
in Ruby on Rails.
Ruby.
Chat, ehrlich,
habt ihr schon jemals was
in Ruby on Rails gemacht?
Beziehungsweise macht ihr noch was
in Ruby on Rails?
Das benutzt keiner mehr.
GitHub...
GitHub hat natürlich viele Sterne,
weil das Projekt sehr...
Ah, das hat auch nicht viele Sterne,
für wie lange das schon so around ist.
Das ist ein super Framework.
Ich finde das mega.
Und Ruby ist auch eine super Programmiersprache.
Aber leider ist dadurch,
dass Rails so ein bisschen
in der Bedeutungslosigkeit verschwindet,
leider
ein bisschen
Ruby auch
dead.
53k.
53k ist für das,
dass es das seit, keine Ahnung, 20 Jahren
oder so gibt,
nicht viel.
Das Problem ist, dass es zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo GitHub rauskam,
weil GitHub war ja ursprünglich auch in Ruby on Rails
programmiert, ist vielleicht teilweise
immer noch ein bisschen.
Aber zu dem Zeitpunkt,
paar Jahre später, war das schon
irgendwie ein bisschen auf dem absteigenden Last.
Was hältst du von Kotlin in Verbindung mit Spring statt Java?
Ja, also ich würde Kotlin
immer Java vorziehen. Das sage ich aber
als jemand, der beides noch nicht großartig gemacht hat.
Aber Kotlin sieht mir viel, viel
angenehmer aus als Java.
Warum sollten die async await
rausschmeißen? Das ist doch eines der besten Sachen
an JavaScript. Vor allem, wie gut sie das
integriert haben.
Wenn man gegen async await was haben kann, verstehe ich nicht.
Das ist doch das Beste.
Und in JavaScript
ist es auch viel, viel einfacher
als in C Sharp zum Beispiel.
Weil in JavaScript
hast du nicht mehrere Threads.
Da musst du dir überhaupt keine Gedanken zu machen.
In C Sharp
ist es immer so ein bisschen kompliziert,
weil es könnte
auch, wenn du was awaitest,
kannst du trotzdem Probleme bekommen
mit Multithreading, wenn du nicht aufpasst.
In JavaScript ist das ausgeschlossen.
Es gibt halt nicht mehrere Threads.
Async await ist völlig unnötig.
Man kann stattdessen einfach lightweight threaden.
Na, ich weiß nicht.
Ich finde das halt schon...
Also, erstens in JavaScript
kannst du es eh schwierig machen,
weil die gesamte JavaScript Runtimes
das ja nicht vorsehen, dass du irgendwie
Threading machst. Ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher,
ob Webworker richtige, echte Threads sind.
Also die ganzen Runtimes
setzen ja darauf auf, dass das eigentlich
immer alles nur ein Thread ist
mit Event-Loop, dass sich nix in die Quere kommen kann.
Weil sobald du Threads hast,
hast du auch die gleichen Probleme,
die du bei Multithreaded programmieren hast,
dass du nämlich die relativ schnell
ins Bein schießen kannst.
Bei Async und await hast du das nicht so
direkt. Gerade in JavaScript.
In C Sharp hast du es immer noch,
aber gerade in JavaScript hast du es nicht,
weil das alles single-threaded ist.
Und ansonsten
hat es ja noch
andere Vorteile,
dass du beispielsweise Sachen im Hintergrund
machen kannst
und es trotzdem quasi vom
Flow her
logisch besser zu durchschauen ist,
was passiert.
Weil du eben nicht irgendwelche Callbacks
machen musst, Threads machen musst
und die du dann irgendwann joinst
und hast du nicht gesehen.
Das kann ich noch
nachvollziehen,
aber dass man was gegen Async und await hat,
ich finde das in C Sharp auch sehr praktisch,
Async und await. Und da kannst du
so viel Multithreading und Gedöns machen,
wie du willst.
Sogar ganz Low-Level mit minimalen
Rappern um OS-Threads und sowas.
Also sogar da finde ich es gut.
So, jetzt
gucken wir uns aber an. Aber Leute, wir haben es geschafft,
1 Minute 39 Video zu gucken, bevor ich
sidetracked wurde.
Das eine ist tatsächlich Multithreading
und das andere ist quasi
Background
Callbacks besser zu handeln in JavaScript.
Ich glaube, so kann man
das vielleicht zusammenfassen.
Eher so einen Fluss hast von oben nach unten
in deiner Logik,
ohne 30.000 Callbacks.
Also ich finde Async und await ist
eigentlich eines der besten
Funktionen, die sie in
JavaScript hätte einbauen können.
Next.
... von 2022 springen und auch das
findest du natürlich hier oben in der
Infocard. Und last but not least,
wenn du mit JavaScript insgesamt
noch nicht so viel gemacht hast, dann findest du
auch eine passende Einführung als Deepdive
auf unserem Kanal. Da gibt's dann auch
noch weiterführende Videos zu verschiedenen
Spezialthemen rund um JavaScript,
JavaScript und so weiter.
...
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was das sein soll.
Ich kann's mir vorstellen.
Mal gucken, ob das stimmt, was ich mir denke.
...
Ich glaube,
damit ist folgendes gemeint.
...
Da brauchen wir auch noch nicht mal wirklich ein Code-Beispiel für.
Die erwähne ich einfach nur kurz.
Spannender wird es dann bei dem dritten und vor allem bei dem vierten Feature.
In diesem Sinne, was ist Feature Nummer 1?
Feature Nummer 1 ist die sogenannte Hashbang-Grammar.
Ein Hashbang ist diese etwas seltsame Zeile, die man manchmal am Anfang von Skripten findet,
die angibt, mit welchem Interpreter ein Skript auszuführen ist.
Und wie ist das bei C-Raute? Ist das da auch so?
So? C-Lattenzaun?
Sicherweise mit einem Hash und einem Ausrufezeichen an.
Und dann kommt so etwas wie zum Beispiel Userbin-Env-Node, um anzusehen...
Ja, okay, dann ist das tatsächlich das, was ich hier meinte. Ja, guck.
Das, was auch in der Linux-Welt als Shebang bekannt ist.
Also Shell, Shell, Bang.
Dass man das Skript mit Node ausführen will.
Und das Schöne, beziehungsweise das Praktische an dieser Zeile ist,
dass man ein solches Skript...
Dann direkt wie ein Binary aufrufen kann, zumindest wenn das Executable-Flag gesetzt ist.
Der Haken daran ist aber, dass es sich dabei natürlich um keine gültige JavaScript-Syntax handelt.
Ja.
Denn genau genommen ist das ja kein JavaScript-Code.
Und dementsprechend verlässt man sich bislang darauf, dass die Laufzeitumgebungen für JavaScript das schon...
Okay.
Ist das jetzt wirklich eine Neuerung?
Ja, okay, es ist eine Neuerung. Es ist jetzt standardisiert. Okay.
Ja. Okay.
Hey, ich meine, das ist wieder ein weiteres Beispiel für, dass das JavaScript-Gremium sinnvolle Sachen macht im Vergleich zum C++-Gremium.
C++-Gremium hätte jetzt irgendeine neue kryptische, kryptische, was auch immer, Syntax eingeführt.
So, das wäre jetzt demnächst gültiges C++.
Wobei, Leute, ich bin mir gar nicht mal sicher, ob das nicht sogar gültiges C++ sein könnte, was ich hier hingeschrieben habe.
Okay. Raute. Äh, nicht Raute.
Ja, Semikolon am Ende.
Ich spring mal vor.
So, was gibt es jetzt? Symbole für Weakmaps.
Feature Nummer 2 ist dann zumindest schon mal ein bisschen interessanter.
Wobei auch das meiner Meinung nach noch ein ziemlicher Spezialfall ist.
Und der dürfte bei dir vermutlich kaum für Jubel sorgen.
Denn dafür ist der Bedarf daran dann einfach doch zu selten oder zu gering.
Und zwar gibt es ja seit ECMAScript 2015...
Weakmaps, die so eine Art Dictionaries...
So eine Art Dictionaries...
Ich weiß... Weakmap.
Ich hätte mit... An Weakmaps hätte ich gedacht, dass das irgendwas ist, was mit Garbage-Collection oder so zu tun hat.
Aber anscheinend nicht. Was ist es denn?
A Weakmap, das kann doch keiner aussprechen überhaupt.
Is a collection of key-value pairs, whose keys must be objects or non-registered symbols.
Äh...
Und wofür ist das jetzt gut?
Why?
Weder Weed noch Weepmap.
Actually uses ob... Ja, ich weiß nicht, was es ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Extend objects from the outside without interfering with garbage collection.
Okay, dann hat es doch was mit Garbage-Collection zu tun.
Ha! Hab ich mir doch gedacht.
Bei dem Namen, das schreit einfach nach Garbage-Collection.
Aber ich verstehe trotzdem den Sinn auch nicht so ganz.
Okay, was auch immer.
Symbole für Weakmaps. Alles klar.
Was wiederum Key-Value-Paare enthalten kann.
Und bislang war es halt so, dass man als Schlüssel, also als Key, für eine Weakmap ein Objekt verwenden musste.
Und jetzt, also mit ECMAScript 2023, kann man zusätzlich alternativ auch ein Symbol als Key verwenden.
Und das war...
Äh... Ist... Chat, weiß es jemand von euch?
Ist ein String in JavaScript, ist es ein Object oder ein Symbol?
Oder nichts von beiden?
Das können wir mal auf... Das können wir mal...
Können wir mal ausprobieren.
Node.
Äh...
Ne, wie geht das? Type of?
Type of String?
Das ist Object.
So, okay. Weak, Weakmap.
Weak.
Map.
Keckel gleich...
Was war das? New Weakmap? Oder wie ging das?
Keckel. Set.
Okay.
0w.
0w. 1.
Value used as weak.
Map. Key. Add. Was?
Invalid Value.
Ach, Key.
Also, das geht damit nicht. Ich kann...
Ja.
Okay, String geht nicht. String geht anscheinend nicht.
Jetzt ist die Frage, ob jetzt Strings auch gehen?
War's schon mit Feature Nummer 2.
Wie gesagt, das dürfte ein ziemlich ausgefallener Spezialfall sein.
Okay, das muss ich mal fragen.
Ist a String...
Äh...
S...
Frag mal... Fragen wir mal Chat-GPT.
Ist ein String ein Symbol in JavaScript?
Anscheinend nicht.
What are the differences between a String and a Symbol in JavaScript?
Okay.
Secrets of Character...
Ja, ach.
Unique Immutable Data Tab...
Was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung, was das wieder für JavaScript-Magic ist.
...wenn das für dich überhaupt relevant ist.
Beim dritten...
Ich wusste bis eben nicht mal, dass es das gibt.
...deutlich interessant.
Denn Arrays haben eine bzw. zwei neue Funktionen erhalten, um Einträge in ihnen finden zu können.
Bislang, wenn man wissen wollte, ob ein Array...
Stimmt! Das hab ich sogar mal gelesen in irgendeinem Blogpost.
Schon Google Bart ausprobiert.
Nee.
Das hab ich sogar mal gelesen in irgendeinem Blogpost, dass es jetzt irgendeine Array-Add-Syntax gibt.
Ja, das ist neu.
Hier.
Oder relativ neu.
In welcher...
In welcher Specification ist das drinne?
Ey, das gibt schon eine Weile.
Das gibt schon lange.
Ist das erst 2022?
Ah, das war letztes Jahr drinne.
Deswegen kommt mir das bekannt vor.
Nee, dann gibt es noch andere JavaScript-Funktionen.
Eine Wertengeld oder ein Wertengeld, der ein gewisses Kriterium erfüllt.
Dann konnte man ja mit Find vorgehen.
Das hat schlichtweg den ersten Wert zurückgegeben, der auf das angegebene Kriterium gepasst hat.
Analog dazu gibt es auch noch Find-Index.
Was nicht den Wert direkt, sondern naheliegenderweise den Index des ersten Wertes zurückgegeben hat,
der eben auf das angegebene Kriterium gepasst hat.
Nun ist es aber halt manchmal durchaus so, dass man nicht am ersten Wert,
beziehungsweise an dessen Index interessiert ist,
sondern am letzten Wert im Array, auf das ein Kriterium zutrifft.
Ja, das ist einfach.
In JavaScript-Logik drehst du das Array einfach um und dann suchst du von vorne
und in Wirklichkeit suchst du deswegen dann von hinten.
Das macht man in JavaScript so.
Das ist kein Spaß.
Ich verstehe bis heute nicht warum, aber das machen JavaScript-Leute so.
Beziehungsweise eben wieder an dessen Index.
Und das war bisher eher mühsam, wenn man diesen letzten Wert finden wollte.
Eine relativ gängige, allerdings sehr unschöne Möglichkeit war,
das Array zunächst mit Reverse umzukehren.
Siehste, sogar er sagt das.
Das machen Leute in JavaScript, ja.
Die drehen das um.
Natürlich könnte man auch irgendwie was bauen, was eigenes,
mit einer Schleife, die von hinten nach vorne durchläuft und so.
Aber, ja.
Ich habe das total oft gesehen, dass Reverse gemacht wird und dann Find.
Also mit total oft meine ich in GitHub-Projekten und Beispielen und Blogposts und so.
Wo ich mir auch gedacht habe, Alter, ihr dreht doch jetzt nicht das komplette Array um,
nur um es dann zu durchsuchen.
Das machen die dann, damit ich meinen RAM vollkriege.
Ah, verstehe.
Dann hat es wenigstens mal einen sinnvollen Grund.
Feindfolge zu bringen.
Das ist natürlich lästig.
Das ist umständlich.
Das ist fehleranfällig.
Und zum Glück wird das nun deutlich einfacher.
Denn ECMAScript 2023 führt die beiden neuen Funktionen...
Dankeschön für den Sub.
EEX000.
Das klingt fast wie eine Adresse im RAM.
Allerdings ist...
Leider falsche Schreibweise, aber...
Hex, Porg.
Danke für den Sub.
Guck mal, hier sieht man es doch auch.
Find Last.
Find Last Index.
Seht ihr, Leute?
Da kann sich das C++-Gremium mal was Schönes dran abgucken.
Auch kleine Sachen, wenn sie sinnvoll integriert sind, bringen die Sprache vorwärts.
Es muss nicht immer 50 neue Klammern sein und neue Dinger, die keiner außer einer auf der Welt braucht.
Okay, wenn es kein verliebtes Beak der Namen ist, dann heißt du wahrscheinlich einfach Exo, oder?
Das machen genau das, was man intuitiv erwartet.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das finde ich schön, sowas einzubauen.
Nur durchsuchen Sie das Array eben nicht von vorn nach hinten, sondern von hinten nach vorne.
Und auch das ist wahrscheinlich nichts, was man umständlich brauchen wird, aber wenn man es braucht, dann ist es...
Er ist praktisch, dass es da ist.
...ein sehr praktischer Helfer, der einem das Leben ein bisschen einfacher machen kann.
Sehe ich auch so.
Ja, und damit kommen wir auch schon zu Feature Nummer 4.
Und in gewissem Sinne habe ich das gerade schon gestreift.
Und das ist tatsächlich das Feature, das in Relevanz ich führe mit Abstand am höchsten.
Sehr gut.
Und am wichtigsten halte.
Bevor ich dir erkläre, warum ich das so sehe, zeige ich dir aber erstmal, was das neue Feature überhaupt ist.
Und zwar geht es noch einmal um neue Funktionen für Arrays.
Denn es gibt nun neben den klassischen Funktionen Reverse, Sort und Splice auch die neuen Funktionen...
Ja, Moment, in C++ hätte es jetzt erstmal...
Passt mal auf.
Soll ich euch mal die C...
Moment, Moment.
Ich guck mal, er zeigt da uns ein Beispiel.
Er zeigt uns ein Beispiel.
Okay.
Ohne Two-Reverse.
Also, also.
Zeigt mal her.
Das sind die alten, das sind die neuen.
Nein.
Wisst ihr, was C++ gemacht hätte?
C++ hätte nicht etwa eine Two-Reverse-Methode für Array hinzugefügt oder für List oder für Vector hinzugefügt, sondern es gäbe...
Wisst ihr, wie C++ das gemacht hätte?
Ich sag's euch.
C++ hätte sowas gemacht.
Und noch irgendwelche komischen, komischen Lambda-Filter oder sowas hintendran.
Sowas.
Sowas hätten die in C++ gemacht.
Passt mal auf.
Mich würde nicht wundern, wenn es den Scheiß nicht sogar schon gibt.
Haha.
Hahaha.
Alter, C++, Mann.
Es ist so klar, dass es Standard-Reverse, Mann.
Ah, mein Kopf.
C++-Gremium.
Warum tut ihr uns das an?
Okay, seit welchem Standard gibt's das?
Das gibt es seit...
Seit C++98?
Und dann gibt es noch Reverse-Copy, Ranges, Reverse.
Das ist so schrecklich, diese Sprache.
Alter.
Was machen die denn?
Dann doch lieber Javascript.
First, toSorted und toSpliced.
Und diese Funktionen haben einen kleinen, aber feinen Unterschied im Vergleich zu...
Wenn man Hardware-nah Coden lernen möchte, was würdest du am ehesten empfehlen?
C, C++ oder Rust?
Ganz ehrlich, das hängt von der Plattform ab.
Und so ziemlich am besten, mit dem man anfangen kann, ist tatsächlich ein ESP32.
Äh, dann bleibt dir ja eigentlich nix an, dich anders da über als Plattform-IO zu nehmen.
Und das ist halt mit Arduino-Libraries dann C++.
Du kannst allerdings halt auch fast C-only machen.
Aber das Arduino-Zeug ist C++.
Das ESP...
Also das hauseigene Espressive-ESP-Framework ist reines C ohne C++.
Aber...
Ich find's...
Plattform-IO find ich persönlich angenehmer.
Ja?
Du kannst ja auch ESP-EDF in Plattform-IO benutzen.
Ja.
Also in dem Fall, ja, C und C++.
Also gerade C++.
Auch wenn die Sprache scheiße ist und immer weiter ekliger gemacht wird,
für so Hardware-Geschichten würde ich sagen, da ist halt mit Rust noch nix.
Auch wenn Rust theoretisch dafür ganz gut geeignet sein müsste,
findest du halt kaum reale, ja, fertige Sachen, mit denen du das machen kannst.
Zumal man auch ehrlich gesagt...
sagen muss, ich finde, dass Rust an der Stelle nicht unbedingt sinnvoll ist.
Der Vorteil von Rust ist, ich nenne es jetzt mal kompromisslose Performance mit zur Compile-Time
so sicher wie möglichen Memory oder Speicher...
Ne, das muss ich anders sagen.
Also kompromisslose Performance mit...
mit...
So weit wie es geht sicherem Speicher-Handling ohne Garbage-Collection.
Das ist ja der große Vorteil von Rust.
Also du kannst dir bei Rust zur Compile-Zeit schon relativ sicher sein,
dass du keine Speicher-Probleme kriegen wirst.
Also ich meine, Memory-Leaks kannst du in Rust auch fabrizieren.
Aber es ist schwierig, sag mal, so ungewollten Memory-Leaks zu fabrizieren.
Du kannst eine Liste machen, an der du unendlich viel anhängst.
Das geht in Rust auch.
Aber...
Es ist schwieriger.
Du hast vor allem so Sachen wie Index-Out-of-Bounds und sowas.
Das ist in Rust halt eine ganze Ecke schwieriger.
Geht aber natürlich auch.
Ja, also da muss Rust...
Rust muss trotzdem manchmal Runtime-Checks machen.
Beste Beispiel dafür ist, du liest einen Index ein und greifst damit direkt aufs Array zu.
Weil Rust weiß ja zur Compile-Zeit nicht, was für ein Index eingelesen wird.
Und...
Also dafür ist Rust gut.
Bei einem Microcontroller kann das von Vorteil sein oder auch nicht.
Rust scheint halt in Security-kritischen Anwendungen, wie zum Beispiel ein CSS-Engine im Browser oder sowas.
Das kommt ja nicht von ungefähr von Mozilla.
Browser sind das Musterbeispiel schlechthin, finde ich, für Rust.
Und man sieht auch, dass es daherkommt, weil Browser brauchen kompromisslose Performance und...
Zusätzlich so sicher, wie es geht.
Gerade Memory.
Dass du nicht aus der Sandbox ausbrechen kannst und solche Geschichten.
Also gerade dafür ist Rust gemacht.
Auf dem Microcontroller ist das gar nicht mal so wild, sag ich mal.
Also wenn du auf dem Microcontroller dann halt mal auf den Speicherbereich zugreifst...
Also natürlich, wenn du Hardware professionell verteilen möchtest, ja, dann sollte das Ding nicht solche Bugs haben.
Aber wenn du da halt mal auf den Speicherbereich zugreifst...
Wenn du dem nicht zugreifen sollst, dann rebootet das Ding halt.
Ja, so what?
Davon liegst du nicht irgendwie zufälligerweise deinen Festplatteninhalt ins Internet.
Ich hoffe, man versteht, was ich meine.
Also für solche Sachen ist tatsächlich C++ gar nicht so übel, auch wenn es eine Kacksprache ist.
C Sharp in der Berufsschule war nicht gerade hilfreich.
C Sharp ist eines der besten Sprachen, die es gibt.
Super krass supported von Microsoft.
Mittlerweile relativ große Community, Anzahl steigend.
Ähm, relativ gut zu lernen, relativ konsistent, auch wenn sie die letzten Jahre über viele Sachen da reingewurschelt haben,
die ein bisschen doppeldeutig sind, aber relativ konsistent.
Relativ gut Libraries für alles Mögliche und geeignet für so ziemlich alles, was du machen willst.
Web, äh, Webseiten, Backends, äh, Desktop-Anwendungen oder Windows-Desktop-Anwendungen.
Du kannst theoretisch Mobile-Anwendungen machen, Command-Line-Tools damit machen.
Du kannst, wenn du so Sachen wie Blazor benutzen willst, sogar...
äh, Web-Frontends damit machen.
Also es ist eigentlich eine sehr universelle Sprache.
Ja, jetzt wo es Index Last gibt, steht der Sache ja auch nix mehr im Weg.
Das ist das, was uns davon abgehalten hat.
Es gibt für den ESP ein paar Sachen, es gibt auch Micro-Python und sowas.
Aber, und ja, ich glaube die, die, die Node-MCU-Dinger hatten auch irgendwie die Möglichkeit, da Lua drauflaufen zu lassen.
Aber wirklich ernsthaft programmieren kann man den ESP eigentlich nur mit C++.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man wirklich alle Features zugreifen will.
Und da kommt man nicht...
Manche für manche Sachen.
Für den Ultra-Low-Power-Prozessor da drauf.
Ich mein, ESP 2 in 3, ich hab 3 CPUs.
Ultra-Low-Power-CPUs in Dual-Core 240 MHz Extensor-Chip.
Äh, da musst du sogar mit Assembler ran.
Für den Ultra-Low-Power.
Haben wir sogar, haben wir mal im Stream gemacht.
Ist ganz, ganz abartig.
ULP.
Guck mal.
Da haben wir, da haben wir Assembler-Zeug.
Ich seh's gar nicht.
Wo ist es denn?
Oh, das verbotene E-Mode war, da habt ihr's gesehen.
Ja, da.
iMovie.
Ultra-Low-Power-CPU-Assembler-Stells.
Yep, Clock.
Ja, ich hab gesehen, dass es mittlerweile Versuche gibt, Rust auf dem ESP 32 halbwegs lauffähig zu machen.
Aber das letzte Mal, als ich das gesehen hab, war das noch weit davon entfernt, so komplett zu sein,
wie beispielsweise das, was du mit dem Aluino, den Aluino-Libraries oder den offiziellen Sachen bekommst.
Hast du eigentlich Tipps für die mündliche Prüfung?
Na ja.
Kurz bisschen Musik anmachen.
Na ja, Ahnung haben, wovon man redet.
Was hast du für ein Projekt gemacht?
Also du solltest Ahnung haben, wovon du sprichst.
Und wenn du, wenn du was erwähnen willst, wovon du keine Ahnung hast, dann würde ich's vielleicht sein lassen.
Also du solltest Ahnung haben, wovon du sprichst. Und wenn du, wenn du was erwähnen willst, wovon du keine Ahnung hast, dann würde ich's vielleicht sein lassen.
Also von dir aus, das sind ja die Fragen, nicht danach.
Kannst uns ja mal erzählen, was du für ein Projekt gemacht hast.
Aber ansonsten, du solltest die Präsentation vorher ein paar Mal üben.
Tatsächlich.
Also, am besten auch, wenn ihr mal jemandem zuhört.
Nicht nur, dass du ein Timing-Gefühl bekommst, sondern
es hat, es hat Riesenvorteile, wenn man die Präsentation vorher zwei-, dreimal geübt hat.
Dann geht dir das Ganze nämlich viel einfacher von der Hand.
Und dir fallen die Sachen, die du sagen willst, automatisch wieder ein, weil du weißt, ah, jetzt kommt das, ah, jetzt kommt das, jetzt muss ich das sagen, ah, jetzt kommt das und so dieses, dieses, dieses, dieses, dieses sich selbst erinnern, während man redet an das, was jetzt als nächstes kommt, das geht nur, wenn man das zwei, dreimal gehalten hat, ja.
Dann fällt dir nämlich ein, ah, jetzt kommt die Geschichte, wo ich das Ende vom Satz ein bisschen länger aussprechen muss, dass ich passend dazu die Folie umschalten kann und sowas, ja, deswegen, du musst das zwei, dreimal üben im Vorfeld und, oder sagen wir mal, dreimal üben reicht eigentlich, aber es sollten auf jeden Fall da auch mal jemand dabei sitzen, der sich das Ganze anhört.
Und am besten ist, wenn es nicht die Mutter oder die Freundin oder irgendwie der Opa ist, sondern irgendjemand, der ein bisschen planen kann.
Von der Materie hat und wo man ein bisschen, kann man sagen, so ein bisschen unter, bisschen unter Druck steht, weil man was Gescheites vorstellen will, ja, daheim ist es meistens ziemlich wurscht, ob es was taugt, was man erzählt oder nicht, die denken eh alle immer, man ist der Wahnsinns-Checker, obwohl man es vielleicht gar nicht ist, also, also, du musst ja auf jeden Fall zwei, dreimal, ich würde sagen, dreimal halten vorher, du musst es nicht übertreiben, manche Leute sagen, ah, nehm dich auf dabei und sowas, finde ich komplett bescheuert, wichtig ist, einfach halten, sodass man eben so,
an dieses, ich erinnere mich jetzt selbst, dadurch, dass ich das ausspreche, was ich aussprechen muss, an das, was als nächstes kommt, weil wenn du es dreimal gehalten hast, dann, dann merkst du dir das, dann weißt du, ah, okay, jetzt kommt der Teil, das heißt, als nächstes kommt das und das, ich muss jetzt das so und so sagen, ja, ich glaube, 15 Minuten hat man Zeit, gell, oder wie ist das jetzt, da gab es doch Probleme mit, aber kann durchaus sein, dass es läuft, wäre ja im Prinzip schon irgendwie gemacht dafür, ja, das, ja, aber die, die haben nicht,
die Standard-Library dabei, die kannst du ohne Standard-Library kompilieren, für Microcontroller, Out-of-Band-Management einführen bei einer unserer Firma über Mobilfunkkonsolen, so, okay, krasses Zeug, ja, dann weißt du ja bestimmt, wovon du redest, also, das tatsächlich, ey, wenn du Bock hast, wenn du sonst niemanden hast, ohne Scheiß, wenn du sonst niemanden hast, es gibt bestimmt Leute, die sich gerne dazu bereit erklären, mit dir in den Discord, in den Channel,
dich, sich zu hocken und, oder, oder einen Call zu machen im Discord, dann kannst du Screensharen und das präsentieren und erzählen dabei, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du das, wenn du sonst niemanden hast, ja, gibt's, gibt's bestimmt Leute, normalerweise, normalerweise, ja, würde ich auch sagen, wenn du willst, können wir es hier im Stream, im Stream machen, aber erstens, erstens ist der Druck vielleicht ein bisschen zu hoch und das zweite Problem ist,
ich kann niemanden,
wenn ich nicht kenne, Screensharen lassen in meinem Stream, weil sonst macht's auf einmal, yep, ihr wisst schon, ne, und außerdem wird die Präsentation geleakt, wobei, ehrlich gesagt, vor dem Präsentationen-Leak hätte ich weniger, ihr wisst, was ich meine, weil sonst gibt's Leute, dann sieht man auf einmal was im Stream, das muss nicht sein, ja, das ist gut, wenn du die schon ein paar Mal gehalten hast, dann sollt, dann bist du wahrscheinlich recht gut vorbereitet, kommt natürlich auch ein bisschen drauf an, wie das Feedback,
war, wenn du die drei Mal gehalten hast, alle haben gesagt, Alter, so ein Schrott hab ich noch nie gesehen vorher, dann vielleicht nicht, aber da geh ich mal von aus, das wird nicht der Fall gewesen sein.
Was die Zahlen bei CMOD bedeuten, okay, das könnte ich erklären, wie viel Strom der Raspberry Pi in einer Stunde verbraucht, pff, was weiß ich, was braucht so ein Raspberry Pi Idle, drei Watt oder so, drei, vier Watt, drei Wattstunden oder so, irgendwie so, weiß nicht, was braucht, was braucht denn der Idle, dürfen die auch in der Präsentation Fragen stellen oder alles erst danach, in der Regel danach, in der, in der Regel, in der Regel fragen die nach der Präsentation, du kannst auf jeden Fall sagen,
am Anfang deiner Präsentation, Fragen bitte im Anschluss, das kannst du sagen und dann machen die das auch, sag, sag Fragen bitte am Schluss, also, siehste, also, jetzt haben schon ein paar Leute Bock, kannst bei mir auf Discord kommen, die Modges hier, also die mit dem grünen da, die sind auch sehr vertrauenswürdig, was sowas angeht, die leaken auch nix, mach dir irgendeinen Call, am besten nicht, gerade in einem Public Discord Channel und dann wird das was, easy Abschlussprüfung, easy live,
okay, siehste, wir haben das Video nicht fertig geschafft zu gucken, jetzt geht's weiter, wo sind wir stehen geblieben, bei, to spliced, to, okay, wo, wo waren wir jetzt?
... haben einen kleinen, aber feinen Unterschied im Vergleich zu den herkömmlichen Varianten, bislang ist es nämlich so, dass wenn man ein Array zum Beispiel mit Reverse umkehrt, dann hat Reverse keine neue Kopie dieses Arrays erzeugt, sondern hat das vorhandene Array in place verändert, das heißt, man hat immer die Originaldaten verändert, ob man das...
... ändern das Ursprungs-Array und manche geben Kopien zurück, das ist irgendwie nicht so ganz klar.
... oder nicht und das war mit Sort und Splice eben genau dasselbe. Auch der Aufruf dieser Funktionen hat immer dazu geführt, dass das zugrunde liegende Array in place verändert wurde und das machen die neuen Funktionen to reversed, to sorted und to spliced nun eben nicht.
... ja, das ist nice, das ist nice.
... gerade, wisst ihr, wofür das richtig gut ist?
... wenn man zum Beispiel...
... so eine Suche hat, also stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt hier jetzt irgendwie eine Suche auf der Seite, ja, ihr habt hier unten eine Liste mit ganz vielen Sachen und hier oben könnt ihr die Kommentare filtern, ja, wenn ich zum Beispiel Stores eingebe, dann wird nur dieses Kommentar und so und das habe ich ja meistens, wenn es was Kurzes ist, so inline, so nach dem Motto hier, Array, Filter, Array, Filter, das und das, ja, wobei, nee, das ist jetzt auch schon...
... das ist jetzt...
... das ist jetzt auch schon so, dass das, dass eine Kopie zurückgegeben wird, ja, nee, dann ist egal, dann, dann macht es keinen Unterschied, ja, wenn ich, das ist natürlich die Frage, in dem Fall, wenn man es nicht weiß, heißt man aufgeschmissen, aber ich finde die Benamung eigentlich auch ganz gut, weil reverse, sorted, spliced bezieht sich ja im Namen quasi auf das Array selbst und to reversed heißt, es konvertiert das Array zu einem umgetretenen Array, ich finde die Benamung eigentlich auch ganz gut, weil reverse, sorted, spliced bezieht sich ja im Namen quasi auf das Array selbst und to reversed heißt, es konvertiert das Array zu einem umgetretenen Array, ich finde die Benamung eigentlich auch ganz gut, weil reverse, sorted, spliced bezieht sich ja im Namen quasi auf das Array selbst und to reversed heißt, es konvertiert das Array zu einem umgetretenen Array,
Annahmung ist im Rahmen der Möglichkeiten gut gewählt.
Also wieder was, was das JavaScript-Gremium gut hinkriegt und das C++-Gremium nicht.
Nicht mehr. Die lassen das Original-Array in Ruhe.
Sie lassen es so, wie es ist und geben stattdessen eine modifizierte Kopie zurück.
Das heißt, das ist endlich ein großer Schritt hin zu Arrays, die man viel besser als vorher, als unveränderliche,
das heißt als immutable Datenstrukturen verwenden kann.
Und insofern sind Arrays-Funktionen zwar vielleicht nicht das, was man nun tagtäglich braucht,
aber wenn man sie braucht, dann sind sie natürlich Gold wert.
Ach ja, und eine Sache noch.
Chat, ich würde mich nicht selbst bewerben, ich würde den gesamten Twitch-Chat bewerben für das C++-Gremium.
Und unsere erste Amtshandlung wird sein, wir lösen das C++-Gremium auf und stellen die Sprache ein.
So machen wir das. Das finde ich ist eine gute Idee.
Was so schön ist mit den immutable Arrays, es gibt auch noch...
Und danach machen wir mit dem USB-Gremium weiter.
Genau.
...die neue With-Funktion, die ein bestehendes Array nimmt und einen einzelnen Wert an einem angegebenen...
Das ist auch praktisch. Ich muss sagen, die JavaScript-Leute, die denken wirklich nach, bevor sie neue Features reinbauen.
In C++ würde das Ding dann wieder sonst wo sein.
Und anders funktioniert das.
Als man es erwartet.
Eben ein Index-Austausch.
Wir entwickeln da ein Rust++.
Gibt's doch jetzt schon. Es gibt doch jetzt schon Craplang.
Craplang.
Äh.
Crap?
Craplang, nicht Müll. Craplang gibt's doch jetzt schon.
Und, und das ist der wichtige Punkt, ein neues Array mit diesem ausgetauschten Wert zurückgibt, statt einfach nur das vorhandene Array zu verändern.
Das heißt, auch die With-Funktion geht in diese Richtung.
Das finde ich eine gute neue Funktionalität.
Nun kann man sicherlich die Frage stellen...
Ja, Carbon, ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube nicht daran, dass Carbon das große Ding wird.
Wie sieht's denn da auf GitHub aus?
Ich glaub's nicht.
Was ist das hier?
Außerdem muss ich ehrlich sagen, finde ich die Carbon-Syntax jetzt auch nicht gerade angenehm.
Nee, das nicht, aber die dürften hauptsächlich initial gewesen sein.
Also, ich sehe es noch nicht, dass mit Carbon irgendwas...
...das C++-Umfeld revolutioniert.
Hat Carbon...
...standardmäßig einen Package-Manager?
Recent Activities...
Joa, gut, das geht bestimmt immer noch ganz gut.
Es hält sich in Grenzen, Leute, guckt mal!
So viel tut sich da nicht!
Also...
Es ist...
Ja, okay, hier ist schon ein bisschen mehr.
Ja, Lukas, es ist auch so.
Es gibt halt so ein paar Bereiche, da kommst du an C++ nicht drum herum.
Ja?
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich meinen ESP-Microcontroller programmieren will.
Die beste Programmierung ist DreamBeard.
Perfect Programming Language, DreamBeard.
Moment, kompiliert das zu JavaScript?
Oh man, DreamBeard.
Alles klar.
Ich bin mir hier übrigens nicht sicher, Leute.
Ist das irgendeine Meme-Sprache?
So ein bisschen esoterische Programmiersprache?
Oder ist das ernst gemeint?
Ich würde sagen, das ist ein bisschen G-Bait.
Aber für ein bisschen G-Bait ist es mir ein bisschen viel Doku und ernsthafte Sachen.
Gibt es einen Mod, der IHK-Prüfer ist?
Nee, haben wir, glaube ich, hier nicht.
109% Coverage.
Ist halt einfach nur ein Bild, ja?
Und welche Vor- oder auch welche Nachteile all diese neuen Funktionen haben.
Und ich würde sagen, das ist so ein bisschen wie mit Immutable-Datentypen generell.
Das ist immer dann sehr praktisch, wenn man z.B. sehr effizient erkennen können, dass...
Ja?
Was true kann auch maybe sein.
Stand das da?
Also, ich habe mal vor Jahren einen Blogpost gesehen bei Daily WTF.
True, false, file not found.
Ja, von 2005 ist das.
Da gab es einen Blogpost.
Das ist wirklich aus einem echten Projekt, der Code, ja?
Da gab es hier einen Inam.
Inam Bool.
True, false, file not found.
Das fand ich damals so verstörend, dass ich...
Ja.
...dass ich mir das bis heute gemerkt habe.
Gibt es das eigentlich noch?
Wird das noch aktiv geschrieben?
...vor oder auch welche Nachteile all diese neuen Funktionen haben.
Und ich würde sagen, das ist so ein bisschen wie mit Immutable-Datentypen generell.
Das ist immer dann sehr praktisch, wenn man z.B. sehr effizient erkennen können möchte,
ob sich an einem komplexen Datentyp, wie in diesem Fall eben einem Array, etwas verändert hat.
Dann sind Immutable-Datentypen eine feine Sache.
Ja.
Und man dürfte davon profitieren.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es...
Wie gut, dass ich kein React benutze.
Es ist natürlich so, dass dadurch, dass jedes Mal das ganze Array kopiert werden muss,
die Immutable-Datenstrukturen nicht unbedingt die schnellsten sind.
Und sie außerdem deutlich mehr Speicher verbrauchen, weil eben ständig neu kopiert werden muss.
Das heißt, hier muss man ein bisschen überlegen, was wichtiger ist.
Ich glaube, das ist ein typischer Fall von, wenn man es braucht, weiß man, dass man es braucht,
und dann ist man froh, dass es da ist.
Die effiziente Erkennung von Änderungen
oder der Speicherbedarf und die generelle Performance der Array-Zugriffe.
Und das gilt es halt von Fall zu Fall...
So, was gibt's als nächstes? Das war's.
Tja, und das sind die vier neuen Features von ECMAScript.
Okay, es hält sich wirklich, ach, gegen Grenzen, was es im neuen JavaScript-Standard gibt.
2023.
Aber immerhin gut überlegte Sachen drinne.
You're probably thinking, what the f...
Immerhin gut überlegte Sachen drinne.
Was machen die ein Jahr lang?
Die haben sich wahrscheinlich ein Jahr lang drüber gestritten,
ob es to reversed, s reversed oder reversing hieß.
Ihr wisst, über solche Namensgebungen kann man sich vortrefflich monatelang streiten.
Neues Fireship-Video.
Okay, hat der ein neues Fireship-YouTube-Video?
To CPA.
Was soll das sein?
It is July 17th, 2023 and you're watching The Code Report.
The Internet has a big problem.
If you look at an image, how do you know if it's real?
This image of the...
Flashes or NFT?
Pope tricked millions of grandmas worldwide.
When you hear someone's voice, how do you know it's real?
This is not my real voice.
It's a professional clone from 11 labs.
My biggest fear as a digital creator is that tools like this will be used to fully replicate my online swagger and make me irrelevant.
It's already happening to people.
Like I legit thought that Greta launched her own oil company recently.
Hello, my name is Greta and welcome to my oil company.
I love how it is pumped out of the ground.
I'm a huge fan of oil and use it all the time.
As you can see here in this documentary from Honey...
Wisst ihr, mittlerweile, man erkennt ja noch, dass es AI-generated und fake ist.
Aber ich frag mich halt echt, ob man das in vier, fünf Jahren immer noch so gut auseinanderhalten kann.
...that borrowed my deepfake animatron to make it look like I'm not AI-generated.
Luckily though, there's a new coalition in town that includes friendly megacorporations like Adobe and Microsoft,
who have stepped up to rescue us from these generative AI problems that they created.
It's called the Coalition for Content Providence and Authenticity.
Was? Geiler Name. Kann sich jeder sofort merken.
...or C2PA. Not many people know about it yet, but it should be on every developer's radar,
because it could change the internet as we know it.
Basically, it's a spec or set of guidelines for both hardware and software providers
that would attach metadata to every media file, like images, videos, audio and so on,
then use cryptography to digitally sign it, making every file tamper-aware.
The idea is to make it impossible to change a pixel without the provenance of those changes being recorded on the file itself.
Or to a manifest that is permanently attached to that file.
The first record will happen on the camera where the photo was taken,
then when you go to edit it in Photoshop, another record will be logged and signed there.
It's almost like every image will become an NFT, minus the blockchain.
You'll be able to click on this icon to inspect the provenance information to determine if that image was generated correctly.
Ja, okay, aber das ist was Neues. Sachen wie PNG und so, die könnten das ja noch nicht.
Ich mein, man kann in PNG auch Metainformation machen.
Okay, keine Ahnung, ob da überhaupt jemals sich was tut in der Richtung.
... by AI, or determine if it comes from a trusted news source like Buzzfeed or Infowars.
This technology is already here, and just last week the coalition was urging the US Senate
to put laws on the books that would make this technology essential.
We propose Congress establish a new federal anti-impersonation right
that would give artists the right to enforce against someone intentionally attempting to impersonate their style or likeness.
That actually sounds great.
Wow, das kannst du auch.
Aber sehr, wie soll man sagen, sehr weiträumig auslegen, ja?
As a creator, I don't want to be impersonated.
And as an end user, I want to make sure that I'm consuming authentic content.
And it would be very useful to companies like Valve,
who have recently started banning games on Steam that are suspected of using AI-generated content
that could potentially violate someone's copyright.
And other top companies like Stability AI are fully on board.
Images generated through our platform can be digitally stamped with metadata and watermarks
who welcome Adobe's leadership in driving the development of some of these open standards.
And not surprisingly, the US Department of Defense is on board,
because they believe this technology can help surface bad actors,
like Steven Seagal or anyone else creating horrible synthetic content.
Sounds pretty awesome, and I love when big corporations team up with the government to keep me safe.
But when looked at from another angle, this could be viewed as a mass surveillance apparatus.
In the future, it may be impossible to change a pixel on the Internet without leaving a digital footprint.
Currently, the spec allows for anonymity,
but it talks about how this technology could be used with digital IDs issued by the government
that would make it far easier to figure out who's creating all these memes that are offensive to our dear leaders.
When this technology is combined with a digital currency and social credit system,
we could easily shut down the meme warriors' Internet access
and reduce their allowance of lab-grown meat to just 12 ounces per week.
In addition, it would give the establishment a monopoly on disinformation.
Hypothetically, they could create all the AI-generated content they want while making it look trustworthy.
And the vast majority of people out there will believe whatever authorities tell them.
Like if this image had a NASA provenance signature on it,
almost everybody would believe that we went to Mars.
Even though it's not a real place you can go to.
In 1981...
Ja, kann ja auch schon überhaupt nicht sein, weil es nicht flach ist.
...on it.
Almost everybody would believe that we went to Mars,
even though it's not a real place you can go to.
In 1981, the CIA director said,
we'll know our disinformation program is complete
when everything the American public believes is false.
This has been The Code Report.
Thanks for watching and I will see you in the next one.
The best stack overflow question ever asked.
Ich reagiere ungern auf Leute, die auf was reagiert haben und dann reagieren, so.
Aber was ist denn die beste stack overflow question ever asked?
Alright, so, I did need to do something very, very, very important, okay?
The problem to the question, of course, was...
What is the best way
to measure your dickt in bytes?
Yep, yep, dickt?
A friend and I were having a boys night out
and we got on the topic of compressions
and unique ways of measure data structs.
Unique ways to measure data structs.
One of my problems at work is managing a very large LRU.
We are frequently...
Haha, keck wie.
LMAO, LOL, VEV, keck wie.
...running out of memory
and estimates all seem to be wrong.
I thought it would be straightforward to measure dicks.
But it's been complicated.
Let me explain the current approaches.
One.
Okay, okay, nur dass ich es jetzt verstehe.
Die suchen den besten Weg, wie man ein Dictionary in JavaScript...
Wahrscheinlich geht es um JavaScript, oder?
Oder um welche Programmiersprache geht es?
Python? Wahrscheinlich geht es Python.
Ja, hier, edit in Python, okay.
Also, die size, was ein Dictionary in Python verbraucht,
das ist in der Tat gar kein allzu easy task,
weil du nicht genau weißt, wie Dictionary intern funktioniert, würde ich mal sagen.
Also zum Beispiel in .NET sind Collections manchmal doppelt so groß,
wie sie Elemente haben.
Warum?
Weil aus Effizienzgründen, wenn die Liste voll ist,
die doppelte Anzahl an Elementen,
reserviert wird für die nächsten Elemente, die eventuell hinzugefügt werden können.
Das heißt, wenn du 1 oben drüber bist, über diese Grenze,
dann bekommst du eine doppelt so lange Liste, obwohl die eigentlich leer ist,
aber Speicher dafür wird schon angefordert.
I could simply measure my dict by using JSON stringification,
but this has its drawbacks.
It does not always get the proper length of my dict, often undermeasured.
I worry that my lack of measurement is due to UTF-8.
I also feel like the stringified dict performance would be suboptimal.
Option 2, pickling.
The second option would be to pickle dict it.
Yep, dict.
For those unfamiliar with pickling, here's a resource, pickling.
I am unfamiliar with the performance of a pickled dict,
but it seems to have a firm base of support.
The protocol version 4 added in Python 3.4 adds support for very large dicts.
This does seem to fix potential UTF-8 encoding issues easily by measuring the dict's output directly.
Protocol V5 discusses out-of-band data.
So there is a potential here for being able to take the dict as it comes,
no matter how much there is of it.
But there is a fundamental problem.
Manche Leute auf Stakeover-Floor sind schon Meister drin im Schreiben solcher Dinger.
You can't rely on a first glance memory usage of your dict.
The nature of memory allocation in expansion and contraction means that it can grow substantially when you start messing with it.
Potential measurement ideas.
I could take the approach of dict measuring head-on by considering the runtime implications of Python.
I also feel this to be the most correct.
I don't want to consider pointers and their weight to be zero.
And the previous two methods really only consider direct dict measurements as opposed to the indirect heap management.
Helping hand.
Does anyone have any ideas how to measure pointers or potential pointer counts within my dict?
I know dicts are very complex and I don't want to miss a drop of memory.
I was thinking of simply taking the sub-length plus 4 for each key and value.
Thanks.
Bin schon auf die Antworten gespannt.
Ach Moment, das ist Twitter.
Hello. We are writing in reference to your Stack Overflow account.
The Primogen.
Your question.
Hahaha.
Die Frage wurde entfernt.
Okay, Stack Overflow ist offiziell komplett spaßbefreit jetzt.
Your dict in bytes was deleted as rude slash abusive.
Because it appears to have deliberately crafted to have multiple sex-based double entendres.
How thoroughly.
Naja.
Not, not false. Ja.
Who wove the double entendres.
Who wove the double entendres into your question was impressive.
But it also made it clear that it was doing so intentionally.
In addition, given that it has been closed as a duplicate of a question which already has multiple duplicates.
Immerhin, die Begründung kann man nachvollziehen.
It does not appear to offer much benefit to the site for anything other than the existence of double entendres.
In other words, it seems that the effort to completely rewrite the question in order to remove the intentional focus on dict jokes, double entendres, would provide little overall benefit to the site.
Regards.
Stack Overflow, Moderation Team.
Tja.
Immerhin.
So würde ich mir das wünschen, wenn Twitch jemand sperrt, dass man wenigstens genau weiß, warum.
Oder halt entfernt.
Tja.
Immerhin.
So würde ich mir das wünschen, wenn Twitch jemand sperrt, dass man wenigstens genau weiß, warum.
Oder halt entfernt.
You're welcome.
You're welcome, Twitch.
Okay?
The name is the dictogen.
Actually, I do have one more story for you.
I kid you not.
I went to Vercel, okay?
The Vercel Conference.
I know, it was a dict move.
It was a bold dict move.
But it paid off.
They really grabbed that question with both hands and just…
Ist gut.
Es lass mal gut sein, Alter.
…getten it outta there.
You know what I mean?
So I went to the Vercel Conference.
And I was…
I was standing around the table.
And there were multiple people at the table, of course.
And I was going through the room and…
Oh!
It was…
I was standing around the table.
And I was standing around the table.
And there were multiple people at the table, of course.
And I was going through the room and…
And I was standing around the table.
around a table and there were
multiple people at the table of course
and I was going
through looking at each person
and I looked at one of the
tags and it said stack overflow
and I went like this
this is all I said this is it
I didn't say anything
else
I said you work at stack overflow
and he's like yeah and I was like
dude one time I
asked a question that got deleted
and his response
was this
you're the dicked guy
and I was like I
am the dicked guy
I'm the dicked guy
hi everybody
I'm the dicked guy like I gave him no indication
into what I actually did
he knew
he could smell it he could see it
okay das war nicht schlecht
ich kann mir
ich kann mir die meisten der video
von ihm nicht angucken
weil das weil das immer so super super
hyper aktiv ist alles da kriege ich
komme ich ganz aus der ruhe
aber das war ganz witzig
was ist das für ein video alter
how nofap helped me get into tech
and become a better engineer
da kann man noch was lernen chat
was verdient eine dorf entwicklerin
das haben wir sogar glaube ich nicht mehr so viel
haben wir alle glaube ich sogar offen
das video irgendwo
ich weiß nicht was eine dorfentwicklerin
überhaupt macht
aber ich ist auch kein bock mehr
anzugucken ehrlich gesagt
is this mini pc you should be looking
at
rasperry
warum warum warum soll ich das machen
der raspberry pi ist nicht wegen der
leistungsfähigkeit so beliebt
sondern früher zumindest mal wegen des
preises
und quasi dem konkurrenzlos guten應該
an Tutorials, Add-Ons, Guides, Header, Zusatz-Hardware und das gesamte Ökosystem.
Ja, und deswegen will man halt auch nen Raspberry Pi haben, weil dann hast du die Probleme nicht.
Ich meine, guck mal hier, hat der allen Ernstes da was mit einem PCI-Steckplatz noch drin?
Was hat denn der da, Alter, was ist das denn? Aus welchem Jahrtausend kommt denn das?
Ich meine, schau dir mein Büro an, zum Beispiel.
Was ist, wenn du etwas Kleines und Effizientes brauchst, das auch gute Leistung und Kompatibilität hat?
Wir werden uns bereit machen...
Weil das Ding keine gescheiten GPIO-Pins hat, was er uns jetzt vorstellen wird.
Tja, hat keine GPIO-Pins. Fällt schon mal so ziemlich das meiste flach, was man an Bastelsachen mit dem Raspberry Pi macht.
Also, komplett useless.
Hat keine G...
Siehste, ich komm aus dem ganzen Video schon.
Also, insofern...
Useless.
Lul.
Aber wofür GPIO?
Also, ich zeig dir erstmal, was das ist.
GPIO sind diese Pins hier am Raspberry Pi.
GPIO steht, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf hab, für General Purpose Input Output.
So, das sind Pins, wo du Add-Ons anschließen kannst...
Oder alle mögliche anderen Bastelkram für Hardware.
Ja?
Da kannst du zum Beispiel...
Du siehst ja hier die Belegung, ja?
Da kannst du zum Beispiel Temperatursensoren anschließen.
Ähm...
Luftfeuchtigkeitssensoren...
Generell alles, was irgendwie digitalen Input-Output hat, kannst du da dran anschließen.
Ja, Regen-, Wetterstationen, alles mögliche.
Bei Sensoren musst du gucken, dass die...
Dass die, ähm...
5 Volt vertragen, sonst hast du teilweise Probleme beim Raspberry Pi.
Ja?
Da schließt du Hardware dran an.
Und nachdem der Raspberry Pi sehr beliebt ist für Bastelprojekte...
Ist natürlich blöd, eine Alternative zu empfehlen, die man nicht mal für Bastelprojekte benutzen kann.
Deswegen ist die Alternative, die der Typ gerade gezeigt hat, vollkommen sinnlos.
Kann im Raspberry Pi überhaupt keine Konkurrenz machen.
Es gibt auch schon sehr viele fertige, komplett fertige, äh, Headermodule.
Die steckst du einfach nur noch drauf auf den Raspberry Pi, ja?
Dann kriegst du dann, äh, Relays drauf und sonst was.
Je nachdem, was du dir für Header kaufst.
Ich habe hier zum Beispiel ein, ein Raspberry... äh, nicht.
Äh, doch.
Also ein Header für Raspberry Pis, die ich, die ich hier bei mir daheim benutze, ist...
Ist dieses Ding.
Ist das Teil, so.
Das macht man so auf dem Raspberry Pi drauf.
Der Raspberry Pi...
Der Raspberry Pi Zero hat genau das gleiche Pin-Layout.
Ähm, und da bekommst du dann zum Beispiel, man sieht es ja auch hier.
Da bekommst du drei Analog-Digital-Konverter.
Enorm praktisch, bis zu 24 Volt.
Input halten die aus.
Da kannst du die, da kannst du beispielsweise dann auslesen, wie viel Spannung anliegt auf, äh, ja, irgendwelchen Leitungen.
Was ganz sinnvoll ist, wenn du irgendwelche alte, alte Technik hast,
die eben halt mit, äh, damit irgendwas anzeigt.
Zum Beispiel meine Tür-Gegensprechanlage.
Die hat 15 Volt, äh, 15 Volt, während man spricht.
19 Volt Idle und 21 Volt, wenn es klingelt und sowas.
Das kann man damit dann auslesen.
Da hast du noch Inputs, du hast einen Relay zum Schalten, noch Outputs.
Also sowas zum Beispiel, ja.
Also als Add-on oben drauf.
Und dafür braucht man GPIO-Pins.
Warst du gestern im Stream dabei?
Das, was wir gestern gemacht haben im Stream, die Steckdose-Flashen,
das hätte man auch mit einem Raspberry Pi machen können.
RXTX anschließen.
Wobei ich mir da gar nicht sicher bin, ob es da nicht Probleme gibt,
weil sind, sind, sind die Raspberry Pi IOs, GPIOs sind nicht immer 5 Volt?
Dann hätten, dann hätten wir vielleicht den, den ESP kaputt gemacht.
Sind die 3,3, dann ist es gut.
Dann passiert nichts.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Und jetzt, wenn es wieder ein bisschen günstiger werden sollte,
was ja schon der Fall ist,
manchmal kriegt der Raspberry Pi es jetzt mittlerweile wieder für so 80 Euro,
was immer noch das Dreifache ist des normalen Preises, aber immerhin, ja.
Nicht mehr für nur 250 Euro teure China-Chinesen-Bundles.
Bleibt das Beste.
NAS ist auf dem Raspberry Pi nicht so gut.
Also, wenn man ein bisschen Performance haben will.
Also, ich finde, für NAS gibt es tatsächlich deutlich bessere Sachen.
Sowas wie ein Pi-Hole kann man machen.
Leider lässt sich mit einem AdGuard oder einem Pi-Hole immer weniger blocken im Internet.
DNS-Blocker sind eigentlich ziemlich aus der Mode.
Wenn ich das nochmal offen, weg damit.
I hacked this firmware and found something concerning.
Wenn das, wenn das mal nicht GBAIT-Titel ist.
Paar Tabs offen, ja, Momente mal.
Ich hab nicht nur da Tabs offen, ich hab da auch noch Tabs offen.
Und weißt du, was das Frustrierende an der ganzen Sache ist?
Noch nicht mal jetzt hab ich die Hälfte von meinem RAM ausgelassen
und ich hab noch eine VM auf, auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
By the way, Nudel mit Lachs.
Beste.
Oh.
Pepo Happy träumt von Pepega Happy.
Der Titel, Alter.
Frech!
Wir testen den Gaming-Laptop.
Warum ist das frech?
Oder meinte AliExpress, ist frech.
Man sollte keine...
Wow, wow, wow, was ist das hier?
Studium Data Science, oje.
Da gibt's jetzt ja sogar eine Fachinformatikerausbildung.
Äh, Fachinformatiker...
Das heißt nicht Data Science, das heißt doch irgendwie...
Daten- und Prozessanalyse, genau.
Datenanalyse und Prozessanalyse.
Ich glaube, ich hab noch nie jemand gesehen, gehört,
der die neuen Fachinformatikerausbildungen gemacht hat.
Chat.
Irgendjemand von euch dabei, der Fachinformatiker-Datenanalyse, Prozessanalyse oder dieses Netzwerktechnik-Ding
gelernt hat?
Was ist das für ein Knopf da oben?
Ilocation.
Gibt's was?
Kennt ihr denn wenigstens einen Ausbildungsbetrieb, der einen der beiden anbietet?
Ich nicht.
Deiner?
Okay.
Tatsächlich?
Dann seid ihr echt in einer Minderheit, weil ich hab noch keine gesehen.
PyHome.
PyHome mit Medusa.
Was ist denn Medusa in dem...
Das ist irgendein Torrent-Kram, oder?
Was ist Medusa?
Ist das irgendeine Blogliste, oder was ist das?
Kenn ich nicht.
Sagt mir nix.
Ja gut, die können ja schlecht für drei Leute dort eine eigene Klasse machen.
Das weiß ich nicht genau.
Aber sie existieren, hab ich gehört.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz auf GitHub gucken.
Hat der vmchamp vielleicht neue Issues?
Ja, der hatte ein paar.
Vom FIPS und vom Missing Glib Versions.
Der FIPS hat Pull-Requests eröffnet.
Nee.
Issues geschrieben.
Sollte ich vielleicht mal merchen?
Ihr wisst, wie das ist, wie sehr ich mich um meine Open-Source-Projekte kümmere.
Meistens hab ich nach dem initialen Upload fast schon keinen Bock mehr.
Achso.
Ja.
Ja, aber den FIA-Champ muss ich echt mal überarbeiten.
Weil ich fürchte, wenn ich mein Home Assistant update, dann geht er nicht mehr.
Das ist ziemlich, ziemlich sadge.
Leute, wisst ihr, was auch sadge ist?
Was extremely massive sadge ist?
Dass ich die letzten 15 Minuten keinen Prime-Sub mehr bekommen hab.
Nein, das wollte ich nicht sagen.
Wisst ihr, was extremely sadge ist?
Dass ich morgen früh aufstehen muss und nach Frankfurt fahren muss mit der Bahn.
Adonex hat resubscribed.
Hab ich, glaub ich, gar nicht gesehen.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Und Darkzone auch.
POG, Leute.
Massive.
Nice.
Kein Home Office.
Nein, morgen nicht.
Morgen ist zweiwöchentliches Sprintplanning.
Passt mal auf, Leute.
Ich muss euch mal meinen Terminkalender für morgen vorlesen.
Ihr werdet euch kaputtladen.
Nekorock, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Nice, nicer Cheap Aid.
Passt mal auf.
Mein Terminkalender für morgen.
Also, ich bin so ungefähr, ich denk mal so 8.45 oder so.
8.30, 8.45, so rum.
8.30, sagen wir mal.
Bin ich wahrscheinlich auf der Arbeit.
So, und dann geht's los.
9.30, Daily Scrum.
Weiter geht's danach.
Also, ich les euch das mal vor.
9.30 bis 9.45, Daily Scrum.
Danach 9.30 bis 11.00, Sprint Review.
Danach 11.00 bis 12.30, Sprint Retrospektive.
13.00 bis 14.15, Projektsteuerung.
14.30 bis 16.30, Sprint Planning.
Ich mach nichts den ganzen Tag.
Es ist einfach, es ist einfach von 9.30 bis 16.30.
Bis 16.30, okay, 16.00 hau ich ab.
Ist einfach Gemiete, Alter.
Was ist das für ein Tag, Mann?
Nur eine halbe Stunde Pause, ja gut, ist okay.
Wie würd ich sonst?
Lumiko, danke für den Sub, würd ich eh abgezogen bekommen.
Ey, was wir alles integriert haben, das willst du gar nicht wissen.
Das ist, das ist Weird Champ.
Gib denen den Elmo.
Ja.
Ja, aber ich, ich, ich müsste ihnen den Elmo geben und dann sagen, ich mach jetzt, ich baue mich vom Acker.
Man muss ja da sitzen bleiben.
Halbe Stunde Mittag ist gar kein Problem.
Wir haben eine ganz gute Kantine.
Die ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Deswegen halbe Stunde packt man so.
Ne.
Habe ich auch aktuell keinen großen Anwendungszweck für, für was benutzt du das?
Ich bleib eh nicht bis 16.30 da.
Ich werd spätestens 16.00 abhauen.
Kann man auch machen.
Halbe Stunde Mittag regelt.
Wie lange fährst du auf die Arbeit?
Naja, wenn man mal Bahnsachen mit dabei rechnet, würde ich sagen von Haustür zu Haustür ungefähr eine Stunde.
Wenn alles glatt läuft, auch kürzer.
Also die reine Fahrzeit mit der Bahn ist, ich glaube so eine halbe Stunde.
Ungefähr, ja, halbe Stunde.
Ja, dafür habe ich im Flur meine, meine Fire HD Tablets hängen mit dem Home Assistant Dashboard drauf.
Ich fahre aber nicht zwei Tage die Woche nach Frankfurt.
Ich fahre nur einen Tag die Woche nach Frankfurt.
Eigentlich fahre ich sogar, ähm, ne, stimmt nicht.
Ich fahre, ich fahre einen Tag die Woche nach Frankfurt.
Das halte ich aus.
Das ist kein Ding.
Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Und ich verbinde das meistens ganz geschickt mit täglicher Bewegung.
Weil wenn ich heimfahre, dann ziehe ich mir auf der Arbeit schon eine kurze Hose an.
Und wenn ich heimkomme am Bahnhof, dann laufe ich gleich meine eineinhalb Stunden.
Einmal eine Runde hier.
Brücke über den Main runter, Brücke und dann zurück.
Und dann bin ich gleich, habe ich gleich schon mein Bewegungspensum.
Ist natürlich ein bisschen unangenehm, weil ich einen Rucksack dabei habe.
Aber gut.
Besser als erst heim und dann nochmal raus eineinhalb Stunden.
Besser den Weg vom Bahnhof gleich damit verbinden.
Mit laufen meine ich übrigens wirklich in dem Fall lauf, nicht joggen, ja.
Mit dem, mit dem Rucksack auf und so.
Relativ zackig eineinhalb Stunden hier.
Groß, große Runde über die Brücke am Main lang und dann heim.
Aber ich kann es nur empfehlen.
Jeden Tag eineinhalb Stunden Bewegung und man hat kaum noch Probleme.
Also ein bisschen zackigere Bewegung.
Und man hat kaum noch Probleme mit zu fett werden, mit Rückenschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen.
Alles ist alles, alles viel besser.
Kreislaufprobleme, jetzt alles weg.
Man muss sich einfach nur zackig eineinhalb Stunden am Tag bewegen.
Wahrscheinlich tut es sogar auch ein bisschen weniger.
Mein Router ist gerade überhitzt, habe 30 Grad.
Alter.
Also ich habe glaube ich gerade 26 Grad hier.
Das ist ganz angenehm.
Ich habe auch die Klimaanlage an.
By the way, ich finde dieses Nudel mit Lachs Bild immer noch einfach mega nice.
Deswegen hast du gestern gefragt, ob ich eher penne oder Spaghetti esse.
Kann das sein?
Weil du das Bild machen wolltest.
Jetzt ergibt das auch Sinn.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der Rackmann noch da ist.
Hast du auch ein Walking Pad?
Was ist das?
Nö, habe ich nicht.
Ich tracke, ich tracke meine Runden auf per App.
Aber was ein Walking Pad ist, weiß ich nicht.
Ach so, ein Laufband.
Oder sowas in der Richtung.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Du meinst so am höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch den Laufband?
Nein, nein, nein.
Nice.
Ah, das ist aber schon...
Moment, du hast seit dem April 20 Kilo abgenommen.
Das ist krass.
Das sind ja im Prinzip nur drei Monate.
Also ich habe 18 Kilo abgenommen.
Allerdings nicht in drei, vier Monaten, sondern so in einem Dreivierteljahr ungefähr.
Oder sagen wir mal in einem Jahr.
Sagen wir mal, in einem Jahr habe ich 18 Kilo abgenommen.
Jetzt bleibt es aber mehr oder weniger gleich, weil ich wieder angefangen habe, Massen zu fressen, Leute.
Ich kann einfach nicht aufhören, Massen zu fressen.
Aber jetzt ein bisschen gesünderes Zeug als früher noch.
Ich meine...
Okay, heute war übelst ungesund.
Okay, heute darf ich nicht als Beispiel nehmen.
Aber es gab immerhin Salat dabei.
Heute darf ich nicht als Beispiel nehmen.
Heute war ungesund.
Hast du...
Moment.
Hast du kleine Tipps für mich?
Fange am 1.9. meine Ausbildung an und bin dann Schule...
Werner-von-Siemann-Schule in Frankfurt.
Besser.
Ja.
Nice.
Kannst dich schon mal an eine Schule gewöhnen, die aussieht innen und außen wie im Knast.
Soll ich bis dahin...
Soll ich bis dahin mich noch was informieren oder einfach auf mich zukommen lassen?
Also, du kannst dich schon mal mit dem Gedanken abfinden, dass du in der Berufsschule wahrscheinlich nichts Sinnvolles lernen wirst
und mehr oder weniger die Zeit absitzt und Noten eigentlich auch nur hinterhergeschmissen werden.
Aber ansonsten...
Was gibt es so als Tipp?
In welchem Bereich wirst du denn arbeiten?
Weißt du das schon?
Windows, Linux, Netzwerk...
Softwareentwicklung...
Welche Richtung?
Ich bin im Bereich Systemintegration.
Ja, aber was machst du denn da?
Oder was machen die denn dort?
Systemintegration ist ja alles und nichts irgendwo.
Das sagt ja also noch nichts.
Ganz ehrlich, große Tipps habe ich nicht.
Das Wichtigste ist eigentlich nur, dass du dich dafür interessierst und dir neue Sachen angucken möchtest.
Das ist eigentlich egal.
Und wenn du dann irgendwann mal nach drei Jahren die Abschlussprüfung schreibst, alte Prüfungen als Vorbereitung machen.
Das reicht in der Regel.
Es bringt nichts, dir großartig was anzugucken, wenn du noch gar nicht weißt, was du machen wirst.
Ja, wenn du jetzt wüsstest, okay, der Laden setzt hauptsächlich Linux ein, dann könntest du dir das schon ein bisschen angucken.
Dann könnte ich dir da auch ein paar Tipps geben, wie du da am besten startest.
Aber wenn du es noch gar nicht weißt, ob Windows, Linux, Netzwerk, was auch immer...
Das ist sehr schwer, da was zu raten.
Ich könnte jetzt sagen, guck dir so Basic-Sachen an, wie irgendwie Netzwerkgrundlagen oder so.
Das braucht man immer.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das lernst du dann bei der Arbeit in der Berufsschule besser als im Vorfeld so abstrakt alleine.
Also insofern, eigentlich musst du nichts wissen im Vorfeld.
Deswegen heißt es ja auch Ausbildung.
Drifter, danke für den Sub.
Pog Prime Subscription, Leute.
Also ich sehe schon, ich sehe, Leute, ich muss so Titel öfters machen.
Es wollen ja auch alle High-IQ werden, verständlicherweise.
Die Sache ist bloß die, Chat, wo soll das noch hinführen?
Wir haben schon den intelligentesten Chat auf ganz Twitch.
Wo soll das denn noch rauskommen dann?
Wenn der intelligenteste Chat auf Twitch noch intelligenter wird, was passiert denn dann auf einmal?
Da brauchst du kein Chat-GPT mehr.
Der Twitch-Chat hier macht das eh alles besser.
Ne, das ist so.
Das ist so ohne Scheiß.
Ich hab, Leute, geht mal auf irgendeinen random Channel auf Twitch und guckt euch dort den Chat an.
Ich hab mit Abstand den schlauesten Chat auf Twitch.
Okay, vielleicht, vielleicht, wenn man manch andere so Bastel- und Technik-Channels sich anguckt, das ist vielleicht ähnlich.
Aber wir sind weit, weit über dem Twitch-Durchschnitt.
Was, was hier angeht, Leute.
Hier hat noch nicht einer mal Digger geschrieben im Chat heute.
Beam, dankeschön für den Sub.
Pay to win.
Ja, das war klar, dass jetzt, jetzt, jetzt geht's wieder los.
Hier, Prime-Sub geht auf meinen Nacken.
Ich weiß nicht, sagt man das heute noch?
Geht auf meinen Nacken?
Ich glaube, das ist auch schon wieder out, oder?
Das hat man wahrscheinlich einfach nur früher gesagt.
Sagt man, sagt man noch?
Okay.
Wir haben früher nicht Digger gesagt, wir haben gesagt Alter.
Das ist aber total out.
Heute ist es seit Jahren eigentlich schon Digger.
Bro.
Ja, Bro, Bro ist auch so ein Ding jetzt.
Chat, ihr seid so schlau, deswegen wisst ihr doch jetzt auch, was um 22 Uhr ist, oder?
Was ist um 22 Uhr?
Richtig.
Ihr habt's erkannt.
Boomer müde.
Insgeheim natürlich Fortnite, korrekt.
Ich sehe schon, ihr wisst Bescheid.
Also Chat, wir sehen uns morgen.
Macht's gut, bis dann.
See you.
Ciao.